une production du studio sf mais à mios
en podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut
nous inviter date seach ph quand tu es
avec moi d'hommes plantes à lui on loue
le studio sfc dans lequel on se trouve
ça arrive avec l'équipement la technique
le hula technicien sienne qui s'occupe
de tout pour vous vous n'avez qu'à comme
disait comme dirait ma mère si tu
impétueux tiers et vous concentrer sur
votre contenu pour plus d'information
dirigez vous vers notre très nouveau
site web studio sf en un mot point ca
allez voir ce que vous allez avoir
toutes les informations nécessaires
d'hommes 700
cette semaine on a reçu deux filles
cette semaine a découvert cette semaine
au sans fil pottoka nord-sud une fille
qui font un podcast aussi une équipe une
fille qui fait expansion double et son
ami un peu nous équivalent féminin
le podcast ma génération c'est chic
c'est julian et tête c'était un groupe
les odeurs de les recevoir encore une
fois un podcast où on parle de relation
de couple de dating de tous ceux ont
recommencé secrète par les confrontant
sur une de la position qu'on a entendu
notre caste salle enclencher un débat
enflammé du rite toutes les
conversations
c'est elle l'arrêté au débordant les
pauvres est elle ramasse parc aux deux
fils par allumer spurs perdre aux
partisans
super le fun de les rencontrer et on va
l'écouter ce très bientôt juste avant on
va écouter nos commanditaires qu'on
remercie énormément qui sont là pour
nous aider à faire tout ce beau monde
hier
aujourd'hui le podcast est présenté par
walt de ailleurs une compagnie qui fait
de la nourriture innovantes pour les
chiens si vous avez un schiste vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui est si vous
connaissez des chiens est belle
nella la nourriture world warrior c'est
vraiment c'est hypoallergénique ces éco
responsable c'est fait à partir de
protéine alternative c'est quoi ces de
la protéine alternatifs fapa de la
protéine fait à base des grillons le
grillon et au chili
ça dérange pas c'est un grillon le signe
d'autres trouvent ceux des fois qu'ils
auront mangé du lion mais non je
mangeais des cheetahs des grillons c'est
la même affaire c'est super bon profil
vos tripes et là c'est brillant c'est
quoi ça c'est très bon puis aussi à base
d'algues et de la gaspésie et de pulp
recyclé donc on fait 10 dans fait des
gâteries pour chiens x puis en plus des
gâteries pour chiens que damien
d'énumérer y ont aussi de la nourriture
et une âme ans trader pour chiens à base
d'insectes mais également à base de
poisson éco-responsable donc c'est là et
je suis si j'allais la carpe asiatique
car en fait qui détruit les fonds marins
qui doit être pêchées donc voir deux
élus travaillent avec des pêcheurs
d'amérique du nord pour être capable de
faire ça de façon responsable
ils viennent également de lancer une
nouvelle gamme de nourriture pour chien
donc si vous venez tout juste d'avoir un
chien puis je sais que c'est le cas de
plusieurs heures durant la pandémie
durant les heures d'isolement fait
qu'ils ont acheté un chien ou qui ont ce
soit qui sont allés chercher un chien en
fait pas si vous avez un chiot avec vous
même une nouvelle gamme de produits pour
chiots spécialement pour le bébé chine
[Musique]
pour vous autres sf 20 pour 20% de
rabais sur leur site web
mon chien sauve le monde.fr fait merci
la gagne et oui le votre caste est
présenté par de vives vives qui vous les
connaissez sans doute pour l'heure
smoothie peut-être pour leur lunch moi
ce matin en me levant je me suis pris un
de leurs familles smoothie avec protéine
était délicieux il était un bon mélange
de fruits
je trouve vraiment une excellente
manière de commencer la journée et
ils font ce dès lors on en a déjà parlé
ici et fait déjà 3 savoir que vous
dégustez et pour dîner pour tout et
n'importe quand vous voulez il ya une
nouvelle savoir nouveau land maintenant
c'est le golden cuit alors on échoue
fleur des pois chiches la poudre de cari
là dedans c'est 100% des gardes et ses
prêts à 3 minutes donc trois minutes on
peut manger sa soupe ou en vol et ses
délicieux si nous recenser santé c'est
tout ce que vous avez besoin
c'était ce nouveau l'an v yves legault
d'incurie fait que le sponsor je le mets
dans une poêle scop lakers on sort pas
tantôt elle fait que j'ai pris la base
de chou fleur de reach ou fleurs avec le
golden curie puis le jeu
[Musique]
je pense mon préféré
j'ai vraiment vraiment bon ça a pris
cinq minutes qui c'est parfait merci
revit c'était délicieux
honnêtement on a un code promo pour vous
au kiel le sans filtre pas de castres 10
pour 10 % de rabais sur votre commande
vive campagne pourrait japan est viable
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il travaille alors dans quatre plus oui
c'est parti en effet craqué aujourd'hui
je trouve j'ai pris trois cafés vous
avez l'énergie mais je veux quand même
je veux quand même il ya un éléphant la
pièce je l'adresse il sait je vais
crever l'abcès dès le début les filles
savaient première dwight je suppute le
bill hall où est charlie
c'est un pas de sens pour le maintien
bat et moi je dis ça mais jamais à l'opa
de sens et du tout que ce soit un non
catégorique tout ça mais moi je sais que
tu m'expliques justement pour une idée
derrière pourquoi pourquoi est ce que tu
veux faire un clip parce que moi mettons
je vise à trouver quelqu'un qui a des
aspirations personnelles elles mêmes
dépendants indépendance financière ont
même site que moi quelqu'un phi phi
quelqu'un dans laquelle notre relation
de couple va avoue être complètement
égalitaire
peu importe le sexe si tu dis je veux
que la relation soit complètement
égalitaire peu importe le sexe pourquoi
est-ce que lors la première date
j'assumerai une responsabilité
financière supérieure à celle de l'autre
personne avec qui je vois est un régal
c'est parce qu'une première boucle à m
salutations sont faites je veux pas
parce que parce que je veux savoir
pourquoi c'est aussi important
je pige vettel expliqué en fait je ne
les prends en rangée l'espagne
chasseuses d'ogres pas que c'est rare
que c'est moi qui fait les premiers pas
fac dans cette optique là qu'on m'a
invité en dette est une invitation à
laquelle j'ai répondu oui juste heureux
si je me fais invités au restaurant je
prend pour acquis que la personne va
prendre en charge la facture puis moi
j'ai un profond malaise face à l'argent
une personne
extraits
man généreuse mais moi quand un bel
arrêt sur la table faut que quelques
clubs
sinon mange avec la première je vais
être dessus parce que vivre ou en
mettant de vivre dans l'espace ou est-ce
que la facture est sur la table jusqu'à
30 secondes je suis pas bien jeudi soir
froide puis comme montrait pas avoir la
discussion j'ai vu l'arrivée genre
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on s'est dit
c'est dix fois plus d'espèces de requins
quand le savoir a réussi un bel ou deux
c'est le moment le plus angoissant
oui ces gens comme moi avec ce que je
viens de vous expliquer moi ces deux
piles à l'oeil
hier soir mamad comme acquis japon passe
à autre chose ont un jardin maman un peu
mal à l'aise si c'est un peu ma les ans
c'est qu'en ces lieux comme quoi qui est
un peu of pi section basse et de l'autre
première dixons le fun ces genres de 150
pièces parce que tu prends deux
bouteilles de vin et eu très peur mais
dit on prend mon point de vue je
comprends ton point de vue par contre
moi mettons saipol ce serait plus ait
attendu d'alloresto c'est pareil je
t'invite au resto j'aime bien qu'on a
une dette à tenter d'aller au resto pour
qu'on se parle un peu c'est pas genre et
j'ai envie de s'inviter au resto pour
que ont-ils pensé en fait c'est
exactement là où je m'en allais à part
ce qui est le contraire j'ai pas pris
position jusqu'à me l'ont sûrement non
pas du tout mais il reste que j'ai envie
de poser la question parce que jamais
ton mal à s est ressenti alors que toi
et moi on voit exemple souper ensemble
tu étudies lorsque erbil carrés sur la
table j'éprouve un énorme malaise avec
nous en tant qu ami tu peux pas demander
s'ils n'ont jamais avec mclaren les amis
comme une espèce de non-dits ou est ce
que tu es une fois ça va être moins doit
prendre le bus
la prochaine fois ça va être une autre
amie pitié mais en même temps de façon
très naturelle mais c'est plus dans nos
titres de dette avec quelqu'un que tu ne
connais pas ces autres en corse mais
c'est ce qui me fait rire - pour moi
j'étais un pauvre ouais mais ça ce que
moi je pense qu'à la base c'est rare que
j'accepte des délais de fac ci j'ai fait
c'est quelqu'un qui a été quand même
persistant parce que j'ai quand même 10
ch
je tapais difficile d'après je viens
d'acheter vite exactement fait que moi
dans cette viande hachée tout lui la
ligne ça va être un mois tout le monde a
gardé une âme en jeu oui mais je
manquais encore en train de te demander
après un mois ça arrive
oui mais père j'ai aussi dit j'ai 30 ans
je peux compter pas être sur les doigts
d'une main le nombre de fois que
scheider des dead formelle de huawei des
vrais dcl mais moi ça m'a encore
totalement d'aller soit quelqu'un que je
connais pas le nom
qu'est-ce qui est angoissant d'attitude
que l'on va parler le moment du but mais
je connais pas la peine qu'on fait
maintenant qu'il dit ce que je fais je
mapa course mais non mais t'es pas aisée
en fait c'est pas sarkozy dit bill
lester plus les faits c'est ce que vous
le voyez un peu le thé de la frontière
que je suis un peu dans la vie on l'a vu
un peu avec passion double je suis un
peu plus difficile approche très
attachante mais c'est ça pour moi de te
laisser rentrer de nouvelles personnes
dans ma vie c'est un peu plus difficile
fac dans les dettes c'est un peu de
cette façon là que je fonctionne aussi
dans ton que je te mens comme tu
expliques si souvent y ont les premiers
podiums et y mettons qu'on regarde le
dating hommes femmes au québec où est ce
que justement on veut de plus en plus
bâti en vue légal team 17 arrêts maladie
fait j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu
de vouloir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre de comme exige l'égalité à
certains trucs sûr que dans les trucs
que comme au niveau des ténors par
exemple équipé comme
le retour du balancier photo m -ca
jamais fait courtiser baie james du
congo puis comme ça balancier mettons
pour toi mais pour moi c'est une fois en
relation avec monde et je suis tellement
généreuse mais je me suis énormément
quelqu'un qui donne beaucoup puis qui
explique pas nécessairement quelque
chose en retour
mais c'est pourquoi les rôles devraient
pas traverser pourquoi met-on vite au
resto dix ans on veut tout reste
aujourd'hui à ben c est ma vitesse avec
de repayer nom de la dette dans cette
logique l'homme étant ce qu'elle est
déjà fait d'énergie on va sortir
amorphe le non mais les primes avant les
contrôles des fêtes là on en est à
version s'écoute sauf moi te sauver
après ça on est deux femmes ça pas mal
pour massa nation mais je vais quand
même l équilibriste que tu sais pas ce
que je pense que j'ai bien des fois la
difficulté à trouver le bon je pense que
[Musique]
mais selon moi moi je suis folle pro
égalitaire c'est ça ça fait partie de ma
vision dans ce sens de l'égalité tantôt
tu disais ok dans un couple on va payer
égal à égal à temps l'égalité à mon sens
égalité de liberté donc ces exemples ci
fait 300 milles puis moi j'en fais 100
milles on met des chiffres absolus mais
ça va au prorata dans ma tête je verrais
pas pourquoi moi je perds égal à égal
qui a tout à fait le maximum de jade de
liberté d'autres gardés de faire des
activités de voyager ou tu le veux alors
que moi je dois payer le même montant
que toi puis finalement je me devais de
rester à maison manger une fac pour moi
l'égalité et d'art en termes d'argent ça
dans un couple c'est comme ça je vous le
trio oui ça va dans les deux sens était
la journée où je vais faire plus
d'argent tu es à date jamais arrivé je
pense que j'ai du temps était à peu près
égal ou sinon il est un peu plus mais ça
va dans les deux sens une journée je
fais vraiment prêt d'argent
ça va de soi que je veux pas qu'ils
puissent le programme travaille dans les
deux
ceci dit dans les premières dates là je
pense que tu vas qui est si ce que je
veux dire mais à mon sens parce que même
si je prends égalitaire dans la vie tous
les jours je j'aime encore beaucoup la
galanterie avec moi c'est pas une
question d'argent c'est un signe de
galanterie payer une facture
c'est comme ça que je le vois je pense
que julian ou six escales et moi j'aime
encore les hommes font ouvrir la porte
ça manque de charme dans notre
génération est mal à me faire offrir des
fleurs fleurs fraîches
ça me fait capoté parce que je comme il
ya pris le temps de choisir des fleurs
de les sentir
c'est un moment qui tout ce qu'il
voulait c'est me faire plaisir tout en
règle aujourd'hui j'attends bien un mode
vie où abondent journée tout se fait
tellement vite que moindrement quand on
prend le temps peu importe que ce soit
d'aller au restaurant d'investir un
moment qualité ou d'offrir quelque chose
un petit cadeau pour moi là ça vous
tellement plus c'est sûr que tu vas en
rapport comme pour trois fois ton argent
par la suite c'est assez me charme vous
allez sortir
c'est vraiment mon adresse c'est comme
un genre de modèle classique que s'il
doit faire les premiers pas si l'homme
qui le rend si ça l'était instauré jadis
alors que la femme reste à la maison tu
es la femme n'avait pas le revenu fac
c'est comme une vieille mentalité je
suis d'accord que la galerie la
galanterie ça reste une façon de faire
tes les femmes on est quand même par
défaut dans un générique plus fragiles
on doit prendre un petit peu plus soin
de la femme de je sais pas au pit et je
dis ça puis moi je suis là j'ouvre la
porte aussi à mon ami mais je traite
galante envers les hommes ou ces
facteurs je sais pas c'est peut-être ma
façon d'être je viens d'une famille
qu'on ait quatre fait aussi le faxer pts
et pour ceux que je réfléchisse
différemment mais je suis très généreuse
dans ma façon de faire envers les hommes
mais j'aime encore la tendresse et la
tension qu'on peut dire que je pense
qu'on 9 noeuds 30 tendresse mais d'une
façon différente et veut pas seulement
par rapport à notre physionomie on n'est
pas fait de la même façon c'est moi
j'aime ça quand mon âme justement se
place tout à côté du trottoir
tu me laisses ta l'intérieur du foutoir
pour une espèce de sentiment de sécurité
qui vient avec ce aussi beau parce que
ge
je veux nécessairement que mon homme est
frappé par mois
tous étaient réunis il prend pas plus de
place dans la relation à cause des mais
c'est ce que je pense que juste de
parler au physique on peut voir qu'il ya
quand même c'est ça moi tu vois ce que
tu veux dire lol comme de prendre le
côté de trottoir
si même pas proche d'être quelque chose
que je considère pas ce que j'en ai au
petit jeu des gens n'aient aucune crise
d'été pour moi ça le tellement aucune
importance que je pense même petit fait
que maintenant que ces méthodes je
m'envoie dans une dette avec une fille
de l'aféas s'attend à ce que je fasse ou
du moins qu'elle apprécie règle le fasse
piquer remarque que je le fais pas avec
des si ben oui mais parce que moi je
remarquerai même pagesjaunes moi c'est
comme que ça semble que c'est ça que
c'est un peu off mais je vois même pas
être capable de décoder pourquoi parce
que j'ai même pas la conscience de qui
c'est une possibilité mais est ce que
dans ta façon d'être éduqué élevé ou
quoi que ce soit comme je reviens encore
au fait qu'on ait café mais j'avais un
papa qui était quand même les politiques
vous êtes mes fins un homme se doit
prendre soin si je pense qu'ils étaient
il faisait vraiment mis sur un piédestal
mais pas dans ce sens qu'on espère y en
a mais juste comme ne pas oublier qui on
est d'où on vient et puis qu'on mérite
autant de respect quand m6 et sur ses
trois soeurs plus savoir comment que ça
lui passera bien si c'est parce que
mettons on parle de de galanterie
c'est la guerre entre les concepts du
moyen âge haïti qui est une absolue
construction sociale qu'un contrat à la
société d'aujourd'hui le cap et aucun
aucune raison d'être le disque est un
son
mettant une plaque de boue six chars mon
manteau jusqu'à les sarthois dessus
c'est comme si déconnectés de la réalité
mais voilà qu'en fait on a gardé
seulement quelques affaires de ce
concept le con qu'on applique même pu le
toucher plus besoin d'aller chanter un
poème pour prouver mon amour alors que
mais par contre non mais ça se prend
bien s'effacer plus est plus le cas si
j'arrête
si j'arrive chez voulu que je garage des
roches dans michael vick là je me met à
raconter un poème mettons ça fait jeune
que des lions
tabarnak 6 avait peut-être un veau etc
noté chante et qui sait que tout est
correct ça se prépare genre ce que
l'oeil et en utilisant un clic riposté
et l'aérien que exact là aussi la fille
de phil la fin la plus physique
intrusive incroyable aventure aquatique
team et c'est là le problème et c'est
exactement ce parce que c'est parce que
au même principe que genre c'est correct
d'envoyer des nôtres mais jusqu'à qui
sont sollicités puis après ce que tu dis
ok ça c'est good
c'est correct dans moins de chansons
jusqu'en c'est réciproque
ok mais si moi je fais ou mettons que
c'est réciproque puisque l'autre
personne parce que j'ai pas pris
l'extérieur du trottoir et comme un peu
comme notre déroute que j'envoie un
message c'est comme ça c'était un manque
de code garder claude et moi c'est ma
décoder la clé pour les décotes non
d'être quelqu'un aussi de ses méthodes
mettons deux premières d'être le tout
construit quelque chose tu arrives à un
certain niveau de connexion de type i
puis le plus de planètes sept personnes
le plus bas les dib dans comment tu vas
te livrer comment tu vas parler tpiy qui
commet aussi un genre de capcom c'est
clair qu'il ya une chimie pin intérêt si
sûr que si tu fais trop gros trop vite
mais ton piqué la relation des parents
du label ces crimes et anticipe à tout
le monde que la même capacité à lire ces
espèces de jeu lost a menti mais ces
deux là je pense le problème d un peuple
je vous mets vraiment une catégorie pour
les gens qu'ils sont à sec et comme nom
génial une approche un peu plus
caricaturer le coche par les choses mais
maisons sont les gens qui nous écoutent
en ce moment là on parle de dating
hétérosexuels parce que ce sont des
moutons
mais j'ai l'impression justement cas les
hommes des fois vous avez de la
difficulté à 8 degrés tandis que nous on
est un peu plus sensible aux énergies
moins que moi je capable de sentir c'est
réciproque facilement je le vois je
capable de lire le non verbal
un homme y des fois vous avez de la
misère parce que des fois mon non
verbale par l'unfp s'il vous plaît puis
la personne à personne il obtient
exactement comment mon dieu mais moi je
pense que si elle est froide avec moi
c'est parce qu'elle veut que je fasse
plus normaux nomme ses cheveux froide
avec toi ça veut dire fou tard avec la
mafia il ya des femmes qui sont
réellement qui joue la gamme de fatiguer
oui mais bon c'est important cela des
gens que ça peut rendre certaines
personnes confuse
je comprends mais même dans la dans une
game the right thing est tu donne quand
même un peu de jus une chercheuse en
plus messi trouve pas toi que les hommes
des fois on donne tort à 8,2 rebonds
mais tu vois j'ai l'impression que ce ça
s'applique davantage à une relation
d'études et versus de dating
j'ai l'impression que les gens à la
mesure à huit de route quand il ya une
situation inconfortable les gens il y
perd c'est super c'est sous que les gens
qui se démontre insistant par rapport à
une situation professionnelle e occe
l'impression des fois les hommes en
général et en plus la difficulté à lire
le non verbal d'une ferme à savoir que
c'est une a dépassé la petite limite du
professionnalisme ça c'est trop on n'est
pas rendu là voici ma bulle et surtout
avec les mouvements qui est dans la
dernière manche juste comme regard de
l'énergie
moi c'est plus par rapport à mon vécu
mais ce n'est pas parce que je suis
tellement sans doute transparente c'est
marqué dans ma face quand une teneur
fois que je pense qu'avec moi c'est
jamais arrivé qu'un homme avait de la
difficulté à me lire parce que je laisse
même pas l'opportunité de devenir jeudi
tout je pense que c'est à cause de ce
mets ton si on veut éviter tout le monde
tout malentendu ces deux éliminés tout
game dans le fond tu as juste les 100 %
à vrai dire ce qu'on pense qu'ils jugent
ce livre et puis préparer ses
confrontant dit
tu es passé avec qui tu trouves tu la
trouves vraiment vraiment un goût ok que
tu peux te pas eu le réflexe de donner
le côté du trottoir en considérant
qu'elle en fait tout y est mais pas
passer la fille a dit et ça dérange tout
j'aime rester sur le côté est ce que tu
veux te fisc et qu'elle te le demande
ça fait comme je m'en fous si tout s'est
rempli de rejoindre bonne différence
entre l'idée de dire une fille qui me
disent je me suis tu prends le côté du
trottoir
si je dis ok je prends le couteau de
retour pour elle sert pas du tout la
même signification que si je l'avais
pris initialement dit ça défile de
prusse les enfants aussi faut qu'à me
demande de faire de lui donner de la
galanterie this la galanterie ça va ça
va si vous arrivez à la deuxième fois ça
va avec l'éducation si longtemps ne
jamais parler un peu comme toi ph neutre
jamais réflexe de le faire mais si je
peux prendre en exemple mon corps mon
copain j'avais tout mon côté tout moment
mais mon copain mais il fallut que c'est
con con qu'on parle t conscience de
cette image et elle expliqué le truc
trop top maintenant il fait tout le
temps je trouve ça quand même très
charmante de savoir où c'est des fois
lui vraiment dans sa bulle
asseyez ouvrir la porte et on en
trépigne la porte mais claquettes en
vaste c'est comme un petit jardin ça
serait le fun des footeux tiennent la
pompe que je puisse rentrer aussi des
petits gestes qui ça enlève pas la
valeur par la suite qu'il le fait non
parce qu'après je trouve en effet puis
je vois qu'il fait des efforts depuis un
mois aux tiges sur soul funk je les
apprécie autant qu'il avait fait dès le
début on la galanterie à mon sens c'est
comme le sexe ça prend une bonne
communication puis une fois tu sais que
c'est la personne ça me fait plaisir
mais seulement mais quand je parle de
minutes de gameplay c'est surtout
mettons mais tente une première des
trois soirées survient chez vous genre
c'est ok les textes et genre est gérant
passer une belle soirée
j'aurais le goût de te revoir plus toqué
alors il faut que j'attende trou au jour
parce que sinon le genre d'art trop
intéressé le pis le puits la personne
mais répondra peut plus rares
dans moi je pense que ces essais tout
faits la rentrée j'ai sûrement déjà
rentrer là dedans
de crem ne te retenir deux exprimé que
george tengbeh soirée parce que tu dis
alors je peux avoir la rigueur que
troupes au sein de la firme ainsi quand
je sors je laisse à ceux qui à l'image m
a dit le père qui va arriver c'est que
l'association va rester la même si je
prends pas j'ai moins soit j'éprouve le
besoin ou l'envié ni le faire si c'est
la bonne personne
pis si tu met cartes sur table
finalement la personne n'est pas aussi
intéressé à savoir la mise à rire après
général dans la vie dans toutes m'ont
dit que j'aime pas soyez intec
transparence à bien aller gaz puis
guerre dans le monde comme on dit c'est
la gueux mouvement puis deuxième chose
c'est aussi de mettre des mots sur les
choses parce que t'es peut-être
peut-être justement de votre point de
vue votre non verbale ou votre attitude
est tellement clair que c'est ceux qui
captent le message et c'est possible moi
je pense qu'ils étaient mieux de mettre
en mots et merveilles à verbaliser comme
ce sera finalement l'impression non fait
mon non verbale est tellement claire non
et j'ai tellement je ne fasse très
express à la même phase dans plusieurs
stations jeunes justement des jours
c'est un face des confortables leila
cheval à l'extrême le sais je le sais
pas si la face d'un confortable est une
tape ce narcisse la fin de la phase de
carte 16-9 qu'est ce que tu as une face
du bec emporta megadrive
[Rires]
mais d'ici là nous sommes à dix ans et
il sort des occupants s'il n'était pas
intéressé mais dans la réalité tout
l'été et a gêné les jeunes oui ça m'est
arrivé mais je l'avais déjà raconté
l'histoire j'ai tripé se rengorge était
complètement et perdu notamment va être
un bon pilote comptait plus jeune et je
posais moi c'était réciproque mais à ce
moment-là ça répond l'avait jamais
communiqué lui était trop gêné mais
aussi les dons l'été comme intimidé face
à c't'heure l'euphorie des années après
on tombe face à face et dans un bar et
là on rigole de ça puisque moi je leur
cap j'étais tellement d'amour avec toi
quand elle avait 17 ans il me regardait
des possibilités comme pas me dire ça
j'ai quand même pourquoi bill di bella
il disait m'ont aussi dit à quel point
qu'on le pensait qu'à à côté de quelque
chose de beaucoup c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai réalisé telle à ce moment là il
n'y avait plus attirance mais montrent
le petit côté julian petite fille mais
ça m'a fait mal heureux parce que je
sais comment à quel point je pensais
chemin qui est à côté de quelque chose
de probablement merveilleux à cause que
j'étais tellement gêné d'admettre mes
émotions à cause d'un manque de
communication - sillage de girls ccg le
faux - intégrer aia spa j'ai jamais
manqué l'opportunité déjà quelqu'un qui
me plaît mais c'est raide mais tout est
comme ça mais n'ont jamais rien il faut
que j'aille on se ramène au canal
lachine le piaf décoller mais n'ont pas
de parent de leurs dirigeants puis comme
tu connais non son nom mais maintenant
la première saison justement
d'occupation de ce qui est fait en grèce
il y en a souvent du chômage ponies
länder les gens faire approcher
peut-être
puis un homme travaille ensemble ça le
tellement évolué de son côté et
habitudes est avec moi qui comme ça luc
raconte moi ta journée comment tu vas tu
as besoin de moi je foule humain
j'adore rencontrer les gens filiale veut
pas être avec moi qu'il ya peut pas être
le fait que juste en arrière puis quart
temps que j'arrête de parler fait je
suis designer salut vraiment changé
assure mais je trouve qu'ils étaient
vraiment été sûrement bien positivement
le nom le vu aussi dans dans aux biches
et nout j'avais une approche qui était
très différent chez beaucoup plus ouvert
d'esprit piyush comptant les à faire en
sorte que je connecte avec des gens puis
je suis aussi complètement je trouvais
vraiment cas manquer des opportunités
justement d'apporter ou de rencontrer
des personnes atteintes dans leur taille
qui va rien apporter mais peut-être que
ça va être une personne qui va changer
d'avis à tout jamais et ne seraient
séropositives ne fait pas le même temps
c'est tellement l'fun de se faire des
bons jours avec un sourire tout le temps
[ __ ] c'est jamais négatif puis de les
les
les événements les plus marquants d'une
vie c'est à travers les connexions se
fait que d'autres gens et fait des
fautes pouvez maintenant un événement
traumatisant ou qui votent élevé à cause
que tu vois mettons le grand canyon mais
souvent ce qui te fait grandir c'est une
relation que tu es avec les gens moi
j'étais un peu comme toi j'ai de la
misère à aller vers les jambes un peu
comme semble être le faiseur aller vers
les gens vraiment beaucoup le tipi plus
je réalise que surtout à travers le
podcast ou ce qu on rencontre des gens
tout le tableau je réalise que c'est ça
qui me fait grandir le plus parce que
peut-être que dans le dernier maintenant
dernier deux ans j'ai peut-être grandi
plus que toute ma vie au complet le
tient en termes de croissance
personnelle puis des 2 d'émancipation
est-ce que là est ce que la la la la
détente s'est faite aussi de l'autre
sens la détaille t est ce que parce que
jusqu à ma portée dans la dernière année
si je te mange très elle le dit d'emblée
ça a pris deux secondes pied a dit un
contrôleur la personne ainsi qu au
préalable puis ma façon de gérer mais
insécurité c'est mal et ce que je veux
et puis il ya une façon aussi c'est
également ce projet une façon de gérer
mon inscrits et mais également une façon
de me valorise et une personne qui est
morte de toc
quand je dis je veux livrer 4 j'aime le
livret quand je les fais pas mon dieu
que tu 1 confortant fakty je me mets
beaucoup beaucoup de pression autant
dans ma vie personnelle que dans ma vie
professionnelle quand je fais quelque
chose faut que je le fasse bien sinon je
le fais pas c'est comme si non je l'aï
su j'ai pas envie d'être associé quelque
chose qui peut à l'image de ce que je
capable d'offrir puis joe hammam ni une
espèce de mon diplôme et un bon mot easy
going maladie j'ai eu beaucoup d'enjeux
personnel si amoureusement que ça soit
professionnellement j'ai pris des
grosses décisions pierre voyelles que
j'étais en train de monter un espèce de
nuages gris en bataille notamment péché
d'après s'il tout le bout qui est en
train de m'arriver cefac djoua sisecam
emporté dans la dernière année cette
espèce de légèreté de fer ayant terminé
leur si ça marche pour ça marche repos
puis moi je te colle blanche est
possible que ça marche pas selon que tu
peux pas tout contrôler et kate c'est
comme ça en tant qu'objet de bayrou et
du contrôle crise
parce qu'il m'a apporté une espèce de
lâcher prise de ressenti un peu plus de
d'avoir la permission d'être réellement
imparfaite demandé d'arrêter de me taper
sa tête quand je fais des choses pas
bien quelque chose qui va m'empêcher de
dormir mais aujourd'hui je suis sa gaffe
aux caf le thème en est jean n'échappe
du bal comme tout axé là-dessus ça fait
limite je pense que ça m'amène en
équilibre mental qui vraiment plus cinq
ou six quotidiennement bien quelque
chose qui me dit qu'on a pour rebondir
sur la question contre olten a fait un
podcast avec une spécialiste du stress
qu'elle soigne les pieds veut la voir
c'est incroyable exceptionnel et
extraordinaire décortiquant fait avec
ses recherches et découvertes comme cat
grande source de gags grands facteurs
qui font que d'éléments extraits ce en
mettant l'intérêt qu'ils ont ressenti
très speed imprévisibilité hacker
nouveautés sentiment de pouvoir le
contrôler puis l'atteinte à l'ego
attentats les quatre choses en fête qui
met dans une situation qui teste et s
c'est peu dire qu'il pour s'ouvrir le 3
des 4
cette façon lamastre s pulsé
si ces éléments là dedans rien peut-être
un deux ou trois ou quatre le tai chi ça
permet de mieux comprendre métier le
décortiquer de le déconstruire de
l'intérieur quand le comprend quelque
chose c'est beaucoup plus facile de
potes ne pas le site affecté oui mais la
maison contrôle toi c'est ça qui est
aimé ton 4 quant à l'impression que le
savon puisse contrôler tout c'est ce que
sa gamme low cost control justement si
tu te montrer ce lot de sentiments par
le contrôle mais quatre quand dehors une
situation qui t'arrive tu te sens par un
contrôle strict à potosi mais ça dépend
ce qui est un peu ironique dans ma vie
parce que c'est dans ma carrière exemple
des médias en arrière des caméras mais
le changement et continuent à me sucer
c'est une vérité absolue dans toutes les
sphères de nos vies mais dans le domaine
des médias m'ont dit que ça change ça
change on veut dire quelque chose une
semaine la semaine après vous faut
s'adapter quoi que ce soit fait que
l'imprévisibilité a fait partie de ma
vie depuis des années des années puis on
ait marché des personnes qui s'adapte le
mieux tant d'actes dans la gangue
mettons dans lequel j'étais dans mon
équipe c'est moi j'ai comme un
changement parfait possibilité de
grandir on apprend des nouvelles
affaires rocchetti je carbure à ce
malgré tout taxer l'eau il ya une espèce
d'ironie dans ma façon d'arrêter si j'en
avais jamais la nouveauté de
l'instabilité
je pense que je trouve ça plate accès
saviem nos rires mais en même temps je
pense que j'ai comme besoin d'une base
fixe y ait des affaires qui pour moi
exemple ma vie familiale m'avait
amoureuses masculines et montois
c'est comme ça j'ai besoin de protection
ma fondation faut qu'on soit solide
le récent ou l'autre peut changer la
couleur de mes murs le temps que tu veux
mais du bardo des briques leveaux dit le
change ma maison touche ma fondation a
doit être solide pour que je sois bien à
l'intérieur de moitié je le reste pour
moi c'est juste le flot de la vie
piscicole horribles ces mouvements type
6 heures gmt
mais c'est comme dans la dernière année
je pense que c'est surtout ce qui s'est
passé c'est que ma fondation
et bon dj de large et des fissures
notamment dans ma fondation et envoie un
petit peu de béton une super de boer à
la tête à tête en mode jet pas je le dis
j'essaie de retrouver un peu mon
équilibre là dans le futur mais je pense
que si tu t'es pas décemment contrôlons
dans tous les sens à la vie
mais un peu comme moi aussi j'ai j'ai
décompté contrôlant puis justement sa
part de 2 certaine insécurité est
piqueté par tous par le schéma de lego
mois du coup j'avais tant parler parce
que ça parle mais tim en mettant mon
contrôle je peux le voir aussi de part
c'est un peu la raison pourquoi je
n'essaie pas d une nouvelle personne
rentre dans ma vie parce que j'aimais
avoir le contrôle sur mon entourage ce
ça me rassure et ses failles de l'ets
c'est justement d'être ouvert face à
trop de gens sous estiment en s'aimant
confrontant puis moi c'est le contrôle
que j'allais chercher ces légers a pris
à l'aide go mettez ce soit peu comme toi
c'est justice cij ou dans des spas
différentes mais moi aussi j'ai un
orgueil mal placé cela vous est vraiment
en fait
en fait je pense qu'il ya qu'on parle
des go on parle d' orgueil
habituellement les tuer parce que
mettons les gonfle les fx press/paul
terme qu'on utilise on devrait utiliser
orgueil fait que je pense que c'est un
bon vol habité deux quinquas tout cas tu
attaques ton orgueil ces genres de
l'amsam arnaquer laissait aller seul
comme quelque chose qui au final
j'écoutais votre podcast avec renault
blanchet sur les sur l'infidélité puis
au final
l'orgueil c'est ce qui est au centre de
la notion d'infidélité
c'est quand quelqu'un est infidèle
envers nous c'est l'orgueil qui mange un
coup en premier c'est pas rien d'autre
c'est l'orgueil d'affaires crise la
personal choisi quelqu'un d'autre à
moins chargées choisi un mensonge a - à
la choisir de passer de passer par
dessus mon - puis rien qui fait plus mal
que ce soit critiqué son choix le petit
géant 13 questions jusqu'à moi je
comprends j'essaie de faire un lien dans
ma tête mais rapidement je décortique
aussi rapidement même si je sais pas si
est-ce que c'est mon ego ma personne
c'est juste parce qu'ils ont un terrain
d'entente qu'on avait passé sur des
valeurs intrinsèques on est parent ont
départagé pleut mes deux chats bien
ensemble parce que ce qui fait que
contre là que tu avais avec la personne
que tu croyais avoir dûment l entente
taxi turmes que tu avais avec quelqu'un
fait que quand ça s'est brisé comme toys
ça existe pas comme ça c'est rien le
tiff éclat choses qui blessaient quand
ça s'est brisée cesser citons
l'intérieur il ya eu un non-respect de
dire non xaxis qu'est ce que c'était au
final si tu te sentais pas attaqué par
le non-respect tes propres limites
il y en aurait pas de problème sauf que
tout en attaque et c'est toi c'est
l'intérieur qui souvent les paquets de
délaisser ses blessures là parce que
justement il ya eu 1 atteint tran anh
hung aux familles pour se compter
mordicus à un peu rectifié le tir par la
suite parce qu'on veut démontrer que
mais finalement puis le perd c'est que
l'âme et on vous en parlait bien puis on
invite les gens à écouter votre pack
avec renaud lemay le l'infidélité vos
dents vraiment d'espoir toutes les
sphères la vie puis une beaucoup plus
large que juste limpide était amoureuse
n'at-on sauf que souvent moi je me suis
trompé dans ma vie ça te servir à
plusieurs reprises pis une des fois avec
une personne qui est encore un super bon
terme on est ensemble deux ennemis puis
ça s'est fini champion super montant est
cette personne là ça a pris un certain
temps à revenir là dessus puis l'action
était même pas compte - puis mais moi je
les prie compte moi qui sait ce qui a
été attaquée ces genres crise ça me fait
mal c'est l'intérieur c'est mon orgueil
sticky qui vient de manger la pire
claque au monde
ces personnes là on alors parler l'été
passé puis c'était ça jamais été comtois
était jamais question de toi ça jamais
été sortie de tomber en paix avec ceux
des rallyes crise si j'avais eu cette
réflexion là au moment où est-ce que
c'est arrivé mais j'ai un peu senti mon
orgueil à décolleté
je répète à qui il ya eu un bris dans
notre contrôle la relation est terminée
ou on patch puis on passe par dessus
sauf que la décision de jean se séparer
aurait pas aura été beaucoup moins
pénible et beaucoup moins une atteinte à
mon état mon orgueil si j'avais compris
qu'au final c'était juste quelque chose
qui n'existe pas qui est attaqué en fait
je trouve que ça s'applique dans tous
ces postes dans les relations amoureuses
l'infidélité les gens ils font toujours
ce qu'ils peuvent mais pour ces exemples
ont un manque à combler dans telle ou
telle situation il va avoir des gestes
comme par exemple la fidélité c'est
peut-être un manque de valorisation
tabor où d'autres quoi que ce soit ou
peu importe ils vont aller chercher ce
qu'ils ont besoin pour eux mais ça
n'enlève absolument rien parce que c'est
important de m'emmener penser à ceux qui
le voient différemment dit la même chose
exemple notre ami va faire quelque chose
puis ça va nous déplaire mais il ya
tellement de monde encore qui existe
je crois mon dû qu'à l'effet ok mais
prend 2 secondes mais c'est pas con
toile il ya une raison pourquoi qu'elle
fait hara de penser que profondément ce
que je voulais 7e déplaire si je les
fait parce que j'avais des raisons
personnelles de lafarge pour mon but
c'est jamais de faire la paix à nous à
mon entourage ou ex directeur notamment
mené je pense que ça serait on aurait
tellement de meilleur j'estime de nous
son art est dans mon impression que tout
le monde achetait en conséquence d'un
outil c'est super c'est le fish dans le
fond mais oui de penser que si on agit
selon voyons tabarnouche n'était pas
aussi important que seul le garde du
corps mais toi ta place le piéger c'est
une question que tout le monde on est
dans le petit champ de bataille la vie
notre champ de batailles individuelles
puis on trace notre chemin avec caisse
convaincu nos bagages bien menée mais
c'est sûr qu'on va peut-être accrocher
quelqu'un utilise pas grave
les autorités japonaises vont continuer
avance il était souvent les actions
négatives qu'on reçoit des gens c'est
souvent le reflet de leurs blessures
télé numérique dès qu'on comprend c'est
bon on apprend et confiait dangereux si
c'est pour nous un racing ça leur
appartient
tout est tellement plus facile à
accepter comme toi changement ça faisait
deux ans et demi le tapis avec la
personne qui après un petit temps un
petit bol est fait au magot toutes ces
années là j'avais six pascal wilhem
fascime sa compréhension la de savoir
que sa part rapport avec toi c'est
extrêmement confortable mais oui
extrêmement confortant puis sur le point
de dire on a tous en main tous nos
batailles on peut pas sous-estimer les
batteries quelqu'un d'autre en train de
mener qui
puis quand tu comprends c'est aussi
taxer beaucoup plus fort qui se passe
mais c'est pas facile par exemple ça
reste complètement et ça reste vraiment
du fil le cabba de décortiquer simple il
faut que sur un espèce de moines
bouddhistes qui sont à l'extérieur de
son temps pour comprendre que sa
conscience existe pas fixé jusqu'à on
est un flot continu l'énergie va pour
réaliser qui finalement légaux des
concepts comme cela existe pas été fait
mais c'est un travail d'une vip il est
important de mettons au moins de lancer
la discussion de lancer la réflexion en
fait c'est déjà un bon port dans une
bonne direction mais même là on est en
train de le verbaliser
est ce que ça veut dire que dans une
prochaine
non sûrement capable de plus mettre un
mot sur qu'est ce qui t'arrive à cames
ans mais oui de former tant qu'élu je me
sens de même ce type il s'interdit
dernièrement d'avoir une situation de
marque dans ma vie de 2,2 pas savoir
quoi forme à manger d'aller courir perd
un courage j'ai juste essayé de
décortiquer puis de raisonner ce qui se
passait quand je suis revenue à la
partie était dix fois mieux que quand je
suis parti juste parce que j'avais
réussi à verbaliser dans ma tête je
parlais pas encourager à verbaliser ce
qui venait de se passer et puis comment
ce que je pouvais contrôler qu'est ce
que je pouvais pas contrôler des juste
d'évoquer main voici le sol le seul
contrôle que j'ai c'est celui-là mais
concentre là dessus mais avoue que s'il
ya quelque chose de tellement le mot qui
vient c'est épuré mais c'est plus dans
le sens et de pury ton esprit put/call
mais le met justement quand il est en
bonne voie et libérateur quand tu prends
le temps de juste analysé plus de
décortiquer tout en tout par les chemins
décortiquer le stress décortiquer des
pensées étaient incapables de mettre des
mots placer les choses dans la bonne
case plus quand tu regardes si c'est la
même situation mais juste le fait de
l'avoir comme un mythe ben toi de façon
étalée évidemment dans ta tête sauf que
ça apparaisse tellement les ressenti
négatif qui peuvent découler d'unix
direct situation ces jeux comme curieuse
d'avoir parce que je vais profiter de
mes jeux comme curiosité pour tout le
travail d'une vie
mais par rapport à ce jeu concurrence à
savoir votre opinion c'est comme ça que
ça s'est développé chez vous cette
espèce d'intelligence émotionnelle hurd
est capable de mettre les bons mots il
n'y a pas de vulgariser de savoir qui en
ce moment j'ai de la peine c'est curieux
parce que chez les femmes ça arrive
d'une façon tellement naturel au cours
de notre enfance d'une par rapport à nos
sentiments d'appartenance dans le gang
de filles quoi c'est sûr chez les gars
je me rends compte que c'est tellement
plus difficile ça arrive sur le top et
audrey des fautes et obliger ces gaz non
tu te met au pied de monde sur un sheep
sinon je t'écris seul jeu comme qu'il
reste à voir votre parcours par rapport
à ceux de votre menu retour mais le
présupposé moi j'ai rencontré une fille
femme dans ma vie qui était de très
mauvaise communicatrice ou si le oui je
vais pas nous mettre dans une boîte de
la personne mettez moi c'est
mais mauvaise comme une catherine louis
mais j'ai quand même plus enclins à
vivre nue nos émotions tandis que je
trouve que les hommes vous êtes plus du
genre à les enfouir puis jamais réalisée
sur ma banque et des statistiques qui
prouvent général mais si jamais j'arrive
et dd2 master petit lay j'aimerais qu'on
parle de tela facchetti moi je me sens
comme ça qu'un celui qui me meut coup
mais oui me fera ça fait un petit bouc
aussi c'est très nouveau dans ma vie moi
ça fait un petit bout - ces sites c'est
de laisser ralenti j'ai eu le tlg j'ai
écouté j'ai 38 ans voire 30 piges et
autour de cet été ça a été j'ai pas tout
le temps été comme cela j'ai eu mes jeux
quand même plusieurs blanc quand même
longue relation
et puis pierre chaque fois ta propre
chef ou de faire des erreurs comme
chaque fois toutes les affaires qui
blessent loppsi
ok quand je dis cela personne ressent de
la tristesse ce qui est peut-être que je
devrais pas dire des enfants dans ma
boutique ne devrait pas passer des
commentaires comme ce puits puis en bout
de ligne c'est un instant le faisant pas
ça juste en tout le temps qui est
apprenti mois à chaque relation que j'ai
eue
j'ai été une partie du problème qui fait
que c'est relation de c'est terminé mais
j'ai appris de ces affaires lui au point
que j'essaye de faire mieux à chaque
fois puis le fait que les séquences en
construisant le pays sans doute vraiment
meilleure relation à 30 que je l'étais
avant mais ton en dessous là dans une
gangue de boys est ce que vous avez de
la facilité chamand à vous ouvrir face à
vos émotions puisque vous vu ou c'est un
peu plus tôt
ça devait nous ça le fait non le fender
savons le faire ou mais en fait c'est
nous autres on a on a une relation si on
se connaît depuis on est les meilleurs
amis depuis juin 4e année du primaire 5e
un document puis comme chez
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
avant qu'il dirige lui même chose de
lombardie pas mais qu'on le pose ans a
dit aussi le vent durant le fait que des
fois on est jusqu'à 1000 patients ont
besoin de bras puis on dit quelque chose
on rit puis on sait que ça veut dire
c'est qu'il ya quand même
puis 11 on cède aussi d'un cheminement
le haggis
mais moi mettons seul genre avant
un groupe d'amis ou est ce qu'ils se
disent ou est ce qu'on dit ou le sait
c'est nouveau dans ma vie d'avoir un
cercle d'amis comme ceux qui apportent
des mecs qui ont pas de tabou mais
j'avais jamais il y avait des bons amis
là mais on restait dans le détour des
vitraux et what's up à calvi et puis
comment ça se passe vite et c'est le fun
quand même du monde incroyable au
cea-leti sûr que dernièrement je suis
comme je me suis comme rapprocher d'un
groupe d'amis ou est ce que c'est c'est
tous les murs sont tombés
qui sait des soirées complètes des six
heures de temps
regardez père gratter père gratter père
gratter plus là mais c'est quelqu'un
c'est comme tabarnak le mois vous êtes
si ça me grattait dans un sens puis
j'aime pas ça mais je continue à à tout
mettre fin à ce genre
tabarnak que je viens de réaliser
quelque chose je viens de réaliser mais
mettons-les la question sur l'orgueil
l'amener ça a été une soirée complète ou
est-ce qu'on me dire il est sûre sur le
terrain puis au final afin de la soirée
chacun crise vient de faire un geste
bout de chemin mais se sert du moins de
mon expérience c'est même nous on se
garde pas de sanction parce qu'on s'est
un peu dur c'est rare qu'on voit loin
parce qu'on savait que ces expects et
mais ça c'est nouveau quand même puis
moi je n'avais jamais vécu avant ce que
je pense quelque chose de très important
c'est de ce que je me rends compte les
personnes qui ont plus la difficulté à
faire l'exercice des bsaar est faux cul
bien confortable justement quand tes
amis tu es le meilleur mais après deux
ans ce qui est en retard au bout du
compte c'est tellement gratifiant puis
c'est tellement valorisant
ça fait tellement du bien qu'est ce
qu'un tabarnouche si je comprends pas
pourquoi quand on se permet pas
justement de souffrir un peu sonné
pourrait bien avoir fait mieux toutes
les réseaux notre vie là dessus que je
vais terminer parce que maintenant c'est
des discussions que j'avais beaucoup
avec avec mon partenaire thé par rapport
à ça parce que je suis moi j'ai un
travail comme tu l'as dit c'est ça ça
car quoi de trois livres de lecture mes
sponsors je lis un carnet puis c'est son
travail c'est tout le temps avoir à
évoluer ou quoi que ce soit mais
gestique aujourd'hui j'arrive tg dans la
trentaine j'arrive à un moment où je
suis comme confronté à réaliser que ok
c'est quoi déjà réclamé canada aurait
pas de rappeler la maudite expression in
your hands the boss parce que
tabarnouche que j'ai la mesure
aujourd'hui à bander avec des gens
surtout en amour parce que je me rends
compte que pour moi c'est tellement je
le sais que c'est inconfortable mais
j'ai jamais nous en ralph enfin je les
fais tellement avant qu'elle campera
joyal et je voyais aller dans cette zone
grise où aller chercher des enveloppes
s'il faut quoi que ce soit je mentalise
tout le temps je tente renouvelons
m'améliorer et et puis le ch francs dont
un certain niveau que je cogne
tabarnouche team quand j'arrivais
quelqu'un qui parle à dire le mot paix
en nous et je ferai tout ce qui est
excitant
oui j'ai l'âme soeur j'habite à dieu
parce que je quand j'ai l'impression que
je me dois également de régresser ou de
mettre mon cerveau à off parce que je
bois tout ce qui se passe dans ma tête
c'est tellement c'est tangible je vois
les choses comme un plus un égale son
radeau failli se puis il va avoir un
autre résultat touche comme c'est
tellement facile de le décortiquer
quand même au stick dans le fond j'ai
fait bien trop de travail versus la
moyenne des ruses en plus je pars en
train de mettre encore une fois mon but
je me compare pas à tout le monde mais
dans ce sens que dans les dernières
expériences que j'ai vu j'ai vu qu'à
limites que mon développement personnel
me nuit gay demandant maintenant ma vie
de coopter ou que permet de décoder les
relations
qui vont être négatif pour toi en tant
que ça le devienne avant qu'il soit trop
d'ego et ça pour ça je pense que plus
tout à fait mais en même temps je
conseille de l'amour puis telle envie
d'amener justement le jeu devient un peu
plus sportivement intéressant mais c'est
le but c'est juste que moi si j'étais un
montant que toi julien et mettons dans
les dernières années je te voyais
justement de firmi de perdre et on
dépose des opportunités de grandir ou de
rencontrer des gens mais je connais on
dit je vais te permettre puis je vais te
donner les outils pour que tu puisse
grandir témoin c'est une manne que je
dis je donne mon amour et mon entourage
mais c'est la même affaire que mon
partenaire comme le temps une nulle je
vais t'aider
je vois des frères tons nude avec toi
consciente et l'ouverture ça mange
vraiment mieux les mythiques en amour
cette approche militaire limited pu
tolérer ou dont on a parlé des cendres
et peut être qu'on accomplit désaccord
avec est ce que ton ami philippe quand
même qu'ils sont amis parce que tu es
quand même
somme toute je partage votre vie intime
et personnelle tpiy petit prix dans les
4 vérités puis après ce mets ton
partenaire
c'est beaucoup plus qu'olympic propos
peut pas entrer dans quelque chose en
disant mais il va faire du chemin piris
à ben ali parce que ça fonctionnera
alors est ma dernière relation effet que
je prenne du recul par rapport à ça
parce qu'elle est et on a envie de la
même chose on a les mêmes objectifs on a
environ 90 points
mais je sais que son chemin il voit tout
ça peut prendre du temps avant qu'on en
arrive aux mêmes réflexions puisqu'elle
vit avec soit capable d'analyser plus un
plus un égale deux types le jusqu'en mai
pendant ce temps le pendentif fait son
bout de chemin
moi je souffle bref aucun cas j ai parlé
c'est la personne la personne qui le
fait son bout de chemin
tous vont contribuer à la même place le
jeu jusqu'au poteau situation au japon
mais sachez sanaa cinq personnes qui est
voir un contre-pouvoir but en est au
même point ça va être facile de reposer
à travailler deux fois plus fort cette
personne là elle existe c'est alexis
permanente va trouver ça va être juste
facile peut-être pas besoin de pédaler
deux fois plus fort qui s'annonce très
facile
c'est un long fleuve tranquille
exactement c'est tout je pense que j'ai
un peu sado parce que moi je comme
faciliter également d'évolution je
m'emmerde
non mais on le voit est aussi un fleuve
qui vont vite en tabarnak mais qui est
double ils ont le talent font flop c'est
la rai jamais des grosses vagues
il va juste fois king vite le l'amour
conditionnelle je pense pas que ça
fonctionne avec l'amour aziz un savon
marché à condition que ce ça rit ça
arrivera jamais ça arrivera jamais
jamais ça marcherait jamais d'avancé je
suis déjà tombée en amour avec le
potentiel d'une personne et parce que
oui puisque c'est complètement malsain
parce que tout au long de la rive
l'échangé je voulais que deviennent le
potentiel de la personne que je m'étais
imaginé qui pourrait sceller la théorie
de l'idole ci-dessus idolâtre quelqu'un
tu mènes place puis le dessus du
tourment d'amour avec la place la
personne et ses commettants c'était mon
ami david il m'avait raconté qui m'avait
parlé de cette théorie là en premier
puis c'est imagine tête au cégep dans
salut sur une feuille passer ta trouve
fois king bed en amour avec cette fille
là la seconde voit ce que tu parles tu
râles historienne en commun que cette
personne là puis cette idée de ses
frites miss facile tombé en amour avec
une aide à la personne comme aller à ce
moment là ça fait une plusieurs mois
après en blanc 10 stations
merci merci pc c'est vraiment la
relation justement la plus naturelle est
facile c'est que genre c'est une
première fois ça a fait clic et on est
juste phone
pigeât deuxième genre testait ouverture
totale c'est qu'on dit tout on cache
rien pie xii ème naïveté comme acquis et
c'est quoi les mecs flac gentillette
idée mais flag de gens qui te vue à date
pile c'est comme ben en deuxième mais
j'en doute mais la première date c'est
comme une semaine
de premières balles au mexique faisait
déjà sept heures du soir à 4h du matin
non-stop
ok c'est comme cela qu'ils avaient genre
connexion que ce n'est pas différent
d'un oued sly me suis demandé s'il y
avait peut-être des trucs ils l'avaient
de ti rapport à la perception qu'elle
avait de toit ou par rapport à elle en
tant que personne ccc petit bébé de
perso non par rapport à ses jetons
jamais ton mois par rapport à elle bien
par rapport à moi dans la qui exposeront
sans trop poser des questions et tu
quelque chose que tu y mets ton tu peux
avoir une personne par bill gates mais
genre les gosses mais à traiter toutes
ses ex de paul thomas bichon il y avait
de l'arc
il y avait de la colère jusque là me
viennent faire ce genre si l'eau c'est
louche deuxième des dons faits il est
quelque chose dont je voudrais là tout
est cool toi moi d'apt et cool pigeât
chèque à chaque check up à chaque deux
fois qu'on se voyait ma tante et puis
puis à ce jour il n'a jamais eu
il n'a jamais eu pillon j'ai rien
j'aurai rien nada rien à dire je pense
que c'est essayer je pense que c'est que
ce truc qui jonchaient première fois que
ça m'arrive que genre yapo genre un
petit quelque chose qui fait que c'est
cool mais jean raibaut marché c'est
comme le il ya rien qui gère cette
prophétie se tiendrait que c'est que sam
pas avoir de compromis non plus le nom
ces 2 km et d'un thé absolue une de
transparence absolue en pourcent moi moi
même georges est ce qu'il n'ya rien que
je veux dire que
qui va être mal interprété et mal perçu
mal si l'accumulation efall bones y ait
quelque chose à dire on le dit si on n'a
jamais levé le ton une fois je suis
comme un fleuve un long fleuve le plus
tranquille en même temps je dis pas de
changement c'est plus par rapport à
personnel m'est témoin je ne rêve que
d'un fleuve tranquille parce que j'ai
juste envie j'ai l'impression de faire
du bac en ford jamais relations sont
incomparables dans ce sens que j'ai
appris et que ce direct chose avec un et
l autre et un autre histoire mais j'ai
quand même l'impression parce que moi
j'ai envie d'avancer jusqu'à manquer je
viens d'une famille plus jeune est
pressenti je me le suis déménagé en
tabarnak
parce que c'est moi qui prends les
décisions mais il ya quelque chose d
comme moi on dit que j'ai hâte de
continuer à avancer par sa prochaine
étape le jeu la pression je ne me suis
pas bien dans le même bassin blanc même
remous depuis que je suis tout juste
avant 6 quelqu'un mais comme à long
terme tic mais jeunes curieuse de savoir
tout en début des relations parce que là
vous parlez beaucoup de hockey
sa perception par rapport à toi et vice
versa mais est-ce qui plus est à écouter
le podcast avec renault du stylo m'étais
moi je suis très bonne
voici où je suis rendu dans ma vie voici
mon terrain de jeu voici mes limites en
tant d'humains 10 comme moi ma vision
d'un couple s'est vraiment passé dans
d'étudier le jeu plein de papillon puis
de chansons droit 19 mai risque c'est
assez cartésien enfin voici mon business
plan
doit on a fait ça fait pas avec lahti il
faut que ce soit sauf s'il est accablant
ouais les faits oui j'aime c'est moi les
gueux qui disent comme luigi ferraris
gosse anglais d'abc y en a plein qui
font mais ils sont pas conscients je
pars en sushi problème 5 et icloud
feuilleton a parlé de suite de genre si
les concepts comme couple ouvert tout ce
que tu penses de traiter toutes les fnac
au pouvoir n'ont acquis c'est comme tout
était déjà mis cartes sur table les gens
qui se pensent de gens comment ils
souhaitent vivre une relation comment
tout sauf active on n'est pas à voir
qu'il ya quelque chose plus finalement
six mois plus tard on se rend compte
qu'on est vraiment c'est sûrement ce
n'est pas par les plus sacrés de des
clash
le cfa qu à notre âge aussi ses
différentes et qu'on aborde ce genre t
on
on a une facilité d'aborder ces sujets
là c'est bien correct puis si on n'a pas
la même vision bien qu'ils menaient
meilleure idée de ce que tu veux puisque
tu es capable d'offrir un peu comme moi
aussi mais bon ça se fait que ce soit un
peu plus chiant mais au moins maintenant
que tu sais il fait pas exprès les
alimenter si tu savais depuis le début
aussi mon cas au début de quelque chose
qui s'apprend avec l'otan mais ses
limites je vois ça comme un signe de
respecter je peux pas de tomber sa tête
si je te lis pas dit je te dis voici ce
qu'ils en aient voici ce que je veux on
veut la même affaire parfait highfive en
serbie jusqu'à mon dieu que c'est
tellement plus facile que d'essayer dé
cela et penser à ça ils pensent pas eu
de suspense dans cette relation
seulement le tente on parlait la game
maison grise
[Musique]
en fait c'est juste c'est là que je me
dis si un bris de contre mais il faut le
réaliser tes paroles je trouve que des
fois on est tellement en amour avec le
concept qu'on reste le pion respect dans
cette relation le sachant qu'on est en
train de forcer dans le vide
pitt et moi j'ai lembeye se saigne lomé
efira toutefois resserrée du produit
chez toi c'est la chose de plus
c'est vraiment mais je pense que le pire
ait clos c'est l'amer règle au monde
entier s'il ya quelque chose tant
participer sûr j'y suis je prête
vraiment loin d'avoir réussi à faire ça
dans ma vie le tipi j'aspire à réussir
sauf que s'il ya quelque chose dont on
parle peu par des chicanes citant par
suite quand ça arrive mais si c'est mal
reçu sept appartient posés çà et xavier
la vérité c'est mal reçue comme ça mais
c'est parce que si la vérité est au delà
des limites de la relation mais là c'est
à ce prix que cela soit mal reçue ce
soit mal reçue ça se peut que ça fasse
bombay c'est ça fonctionne mais au moins
te peau comme band et et eva leurs
petites têtes étaient à faire pour te
rendre plus loin pour finalement faire
exploser des shows d'assumer ses actes
pour que ça ait de la communication
c'est justement dans des situations
conflictuelles ou justement toutes les
émotions qu'ils embarquent était la
difficulté est exprimé ou quoi que ce
soit mais c'était avant de revenir
justement être trop têtu il ya des sauts
dans le bus il est maire pour compliquer
de marcher à côté mon job comme voici ce
qui s'est passé en m'intéressant
facilite la compréhension de ce que j'ai
fait
ah c'est ça que ça dégage et c'est pour
ça que tu es fort j'espère c'est
peut-être la peine dans le fond tu es
déçu aquifère fait je m'excuse
ça se peut qu'au fil du temps surtout
quand des coupes qui aurait récents
semblent des années des années mais ça
se peut qu'il y mettiez volume 5 at il
dit mais c'est à responsabilités aussi
dire regardez comme ebay terme notre
dame où la même on dit que j'ai envie
d'aller voir ailleurs si j'y prends
besoins sexuels seraient ouvertes à ce
qu'on laissait retraite ou verticaux
mais monde il faut tu dis non
non j'étais en vie dans l'exemple face
ils apprennent enfin quelqu'un qui comme
au début j'ai poste un boulanger qui
était bien confortable à saint henri qui
avait pas envie de voyager pire c'est
que finalement ça est temps d'aller
s'installer à hawaï les poké ball
j'ai pas vraiment à l'extrême match
comme on évolue ça se peut qu'on est
nous faisons un pin aux envies changent
petit ben correct puis ça c'est vrai
puis aussi chaque relation chaque choc
et ses relations qui creek des
différentes personnes doit différente
parce que les règles non écrites que tu
avais avec intel qui sont installés au
fil du temps ou même temps par la
communication se fait qu'elle soit
différent techno personne parce que ça
crée chaque relation créer une nouvelle
dynamique qui est qu' une équipe qui ne
trouvera jamais appris petit ccc chaque
chaque moment comme ça moi c'est drôle
c'est le moment l'autre je vais dire
quelque chose
si la londe présentant attention à vos
trousses of kings tablant de présenter
petite heure des futures dépenses des
ménages dans un discours très bon disque
double j'avais didier fauthoux là-dessus
d'avant elle coûte pour le podcast qui
tombent sur des photos de voyage avec
mon ex je tombe là dessus plus chatel
soon as à me rappeler à faire plus je
vois les photos plus comme venu un peu
le motton gentils chez nikon et moitié
vrai motif pilule ou à tout ça parce que
je faisais ça c'est moi qui ai souhaité
plus moi qui était mené cette relation
là j'ai toujours été en paix avec soi
puisque le plus voir sur pourquoi ça me
fait sentir comme ceux qui ça m'arrive
de faux de penser peau juste aimé genre
à tout mais dans le fond puis m'ennuie
pu avoir un peu de temps parce que
arrêter toutes ces personnes là c'est
des belles personnes qui gèrent chaque
chose qui était mais chacune de ces
personnes là on dirait qu'une fois qui
est parti
parti c'est parti jean thissen chaque
personne non là quelque chose d'inné en
fait de chaillot qu'un deuil et va se
passer personne parce que tu es la
plupart sont cuits vraiment dans ma vie
hulu loin d'un tri les anneaux y en a
une qui travaillent encore avec des fois
c'est court mais c'est quand même ces
personnes était tellement important dans
ma ville après ça juste disparu puis
jorge aimait tellement tu l as far ces
personnes là puis j'aimais tellement
pire c est qu on dirait que c'est comme
triste d'après ce que ce soit
complètement fini ses personnels quand
même leurs traces très fière de toi
factice et ils sont partis mais pire
encore les soutenaient que tu habites un
peu comme quelqu'un qui marche
mais moi je les garde ses souvenirs là
bas oui ça fait partie de mon parcours
puis si j'ai encore des photos sur mon
écran avec mon exploit parce que je
pense un jour revenir avec aucune matin
si c'est juste que ça fait partie de mon
parcours de mon histoire qui pour moi
ces moments là ma porte justement un
espèce de jeu c'est pas un genre de
réconfort puis c'est pas nécessairement
par rapport à notre relation mais
peut-être les moments qu'on a vécus
ensemble et puis moi je trouve ça beau
on dirait qu'elle jamais qu'elle
imposerait sa motion et d'effacer ses
soins route est très important un crime
ça fait de la personne en fait le chemin
parcouru fait en sorte qu' en ce moment
on est confronté que la somme des
expériences ainsi qu'un coran avec
quelqu'un tout ça sur notre choix ou peu
de choix c'est donc mon ex copain et je
laime jeunes ont profondément c'est pas
parce que je laime peuvent pour ceux que
ça a été dans maints difficile je
l'aimais ce qu'on était en ce moment là
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on voulait
nécessairement quand on rompt d'une
personne c'est pas la personne qu'on
jette oppidum je le sais pas si c'est
juste que le duo n'était pas bon des
bols bon film mais c'est normal qu'on
éprouve encore de l'amour pour d'autres
personnes
l'amour évolue la moue change on peut
avoir la tendresse quoi que ce soit mais
c'est juste différente et après se sait
capable de le faire la paire dé la part
des choses ouais parce que moi j'ai
jamais compris les gens qui le détestent
ou sont en mauvais terme être le rex
comme
c'est vraiment une chance à loos lez
toutes les ex c'est là que c'est une ex
qui comme elle ont séché cadas
amalfitano ces gens ça se passe ça se
peut mais tout comme si vous êtes à tous
les lecteurs
l'exemple dit que si tu penses trop
sûrement de la marde c'est ça sa marque
partout et souvent c'est sûrement tokyo
[Rires]
c'est patrick roy qui avait avec et qui
a fait au démon année il faisait yves
joueurs ok puis son meilleur ami c'était
dur oif et connaissait bien patrick puis
amené cendriers des gens aussi pris bien
des pas dire que toutes ces coachs
étaient des imbéciles dessus c'était
tout des cas toutes ces causes tdk plane
et patata ils s'imbriquent sa marque
partout et sont maintenant que lorsque
toute école qui sont des câbles en tout
pour toute l'italie
peut-être que j'ai tendance non mais
c'est un bon reflet que je pense de se
demander si si si quelque chose qu'on a
fait ou si quelque chose qui mais c'est
la réalité c'est que tout le temps mais
c'est sûr que c'est un bon réflexe mais
oui ça c'est off de savoir quand tu es
dedans si d'aucun conflit le thé est ce
qu est ce que c est ce que c'est moi qui
ait fait quelque chose de pas correct
parce que je me suis mal exprimé est ce
que si ce que ce que j'ai tout à fait
correct mais c'était vraiment mal
perçues ou est ce que justement c'est
entre les deux c'est juste un mauvais
fit quand tu es dans ces deux affaires
bronze est pour ça qu à l'exercice de
décortiquer les remèdes sur un filon de
temps à comprendre quelque chose d un
impact sur l affaire la perception a pas
été bien reçu votre été moi j'écris tout
accepter pour ce qui est
en train de les avoir s'est trop
longtemps tantôt qu'un code d'accès pour
les salles et les trucs aussi avec leurs
gains tout le temps justement toute
attente augmenté ici le prix l'exemple
l'exemple classique de genre la
communication de genre montsho mais il
voudrait aller voir ailleurs ou na na na
pas pau puis tout à fait catégorie
explique moi pourquoi c'est un non
catégorique au salon catégorique mais
pour mon intimité
c'est très important j'ai pas partager
mon intimité très souvent dans ma vie
pour moi c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je chéris donc si je joue je m'ouvre
toit du code allemand mais pour moi ici
je sais pas ça fait partie d'un tout ça
fait partie de quelque chose qu'on que
je veux vivre à deux et seulement 2 si
un jour dans ma vie dans le domaine
mon mari au tour des enfants mon mari
dit à juliet et j'aime rester avec moi
ça va être plus à être pourquoi explique
moi pourquoi pas prendre antiquités mais
ça sera rendu le parce que en ce moment
ce que je ressens c'est beau ce que je
veux vraiment que ça soit juste en deux
personnes puis voilà non pire maintenant
vous êtes une vraie relation ne se
serait à y mettre un peu étrange que th
déjà tanné de son père il ancienne
relation j'ai jamais eu cette ouverture
non le clip ces corrections en à quillan
moi moi moi mon intimité c'est juste
très important c'est mon petit cocon
c'est mon safe tout laisse donc voilà
mais six autres mets ton parce que
l'hôte et on prend l'exemple de l'homme
qui met cette discussion là métier
mettons vous autres ça vous est déjà
arrivé dans une relation pis de trouver
un autre labo d'avoir invité de c est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui ça nous
arrive tous les cent ans
[Musique]
je mets mon cas c'est ça mais bt est
capable de voir un gars d'entre deux
tours des trois opéras qui c'est un bel
homme et d'avoir une attirance vraiment
où est ce que jusqu'au bout j'ai un peu
des pulsions mais moi c'est là que je me
pose la question ce qui était réellement
en amour en ce moment ce qui était bien
dans ta relation parce que si j'ai ses
pulsions là pour moi c'est pas normal
puis toutes les fois que je les ai eus
ce parce que c'était une relation qui tu
es mais dont parce que je me laisse pas
aller là j'ouvre pas de porc mais c'est
un peu ça je pense tu mets ton mettons
tu trouves pas de porte puis que 15
cette réflexion note arrive t'on mindset
par défaut c'est de dire c'est pas
normal ce soit que tu es prêt après
l'avoir analysée ouais parce que je me
rappelle d'une certaine relation ou
est-ce que moi ça m'est jamais arrivé en
fait d'avoir ses pulsions le jeudi j'ai
souvent été en congé longue relation
puis je vais te tendre rappeler cette
relation là un moment donné on était
dans un événement j'ai vu un autre homme
que j'ai fait
ouf waouh j'ai comme été porté à aller
vers lui pour après m'arrêter et j'ai
hâte d'être en couple nantais puis à ce
moment là je reviens à la maison j'ai
essayé d'analyser ce comportement là
parce que pour moi c'était peu naturel
et la cellule je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait peut-être que j'étais pas
avec la bonne personne
puis est ce que là est ce que tu étais
pas avec la bonne personne ou est-ce que
le feu déclenché ce raisonnement lot
amené à
a poussé un petit peu pour la réponse
serait c'est un peu ce que je pense que
sa solution avec la bonne personne mais
quand même à voir ses pulsions l'autisme
est aussi une longue relation très
longue
c'est ce que dans deux d'entre eux
arrivent et que tu vas avoir des
pulsions des envies d'été dick roche des
affaires
mais qui dit que ma relation vaut plus
que sexy mais c'est le cas même amené
sumène si ces raisonnements là est
l'élément déclencheur je demande du fait
qu'il ya finalement peut-être que je pas
que la bonne personne puis que l'autre
mais ouvre cinq des affaires pierre
juste faire même si internationales
enquêtaient somme toute bien que c'était
le seul accroc qui s'est passé c'est que
j'ai vu un gars en épis de maïs
j'étais pas bien la base parce que
c'était tellement une bonne personne que
je pense que j'essaie de me convaincre
que j'étais bel et bien ma place puis
que je devais lui donner une chance puis
après je me suis dit je pense que c'est
juste pas le bon fit mais jamais la même
chose mais en fait je les laissais parce
que j'avais vraiment envie d'aller me
retrouver dans l'intimité de l'autre
personne plus de trois fois je te
confronter à lui puis ça même à face et
la relation s'était rendu ce fait
plusieurs années qu'on est ensemble que
je ressentais même plus le désert pour
mon propre porter si j'avais plus envie
de me coller j'avais plus envie de
sexualité avec lui le gip rouvert le
désert mais c'était beaucoup plus que du
sexe c'était de l'intimité à limite je
les laissais parce que puis-je et
espérons engager des coûts j'ai profité
de telle ou telle chose j'en suis venu à
la réflexion que on est peut-être plus
tiges plus en amour avec toi on est
rendus des amis j'ai pu en partant envie
de partager mon intimité alors que chez
une femme qui aime le sexe ça fait
partie de mon quotidien plus calmes avec
toi fait des mois qu'ils me ton que je
me force l'été jusqu'à manquer laisse
pas normal ceci dit avec l'autre
partenaire parce que j'avais laissé puis
vous êtes un peu plus tôt
c'est dans les bourgs l'autre mais ça a
quand même pris un certain temps avant
qu'on arrive à l'acte sexuel ce seul
pays même si j'avais un opposition
sexuelle je me rendais compte que
c'était plus que juste physique cela ça
peut-être quelques semaines que j'avais
juste envie de coller son odeur les
phéromones parler oui mais je me rendais
bien compte que c'était encore plus
profond que juste du sexe et ce n'est
pas un besoin physique parce qu'on
dirait que petit je veux parler pour moi
mon dieu que c'est tout est
interconnecté
- mon attirance physique envers
quelqu'un le fait qu'elle g
goût de partager un moment intime mais
ça va aller aussi avec l'attirance que
j'ai en général de cette personne ne
tient la personne à des comportements
qui m'attire moins ou kimpton neuf
belges
ça me tente report d'aller dans le lien
avec cette personne
puis pas parce que j'ai pas de désir
sexuel là au moins c'est juste que je
peux capable de faire la part des choses
des sigles du monde sont capables de
coucher avec une personne juste pour le
sexe moi je préfère de palin 12 centres
est interconnecté fax et l'autre que
quand je ressens saab et c'est là que je
me dis que c'est peut-être avec la
chicane je pense assez de mémoire
interne et qui sont comme le sexe après
une chicane ce comme normand à force de
chicane et j'ai pu en victoire cash
quand même con sur le plus jeune des
deux fait aujourd'hui c'est comme la
semoy vive émotion parce que je pense
être connecté je pensais plus en
affaires la femme si le scanner ça vous
ayez pas en ligne avec notre banque
maintenant fond la question qui se pose
est ce que ça vous étudiants arrivés
puis ce genre une fois puis une fois
puis ont laissé leurs partenaires j'ai
pas d'assez de main pour compter les
fois où ce qu'ils attendent une relation
était super sexy oui parce que parce que
de séparer les deux la facilité a
séparés seulement la sexualité de
l'amour ou sinon téléphone vers un web
ou les deux mais on va peut-être plus de
gomme et des filles aussi
oui je reconnais mais mettons ces métaux
quelqu'un mettons vous avez vous avez un
partenaire qui vous explique c'est du
garde moi mettons illégaux est d'accord
sur tout et griot l'amour pour moi qui
est vraiment important que c'est une
personne city jô juste donné mon amour à
une personne puis je veux m'investir
dans une relation
mais pour moi sexe et amour c'est les
choses sont complètement déconnectés je
peux cacher qu'une fille jamais reparler
après pis c'est pas correct puis ça se
peut que sim et ont amené jetant
l'extérieur pour je sais pas quelles
raisons ont piqué je pense d'abord une
fois puis qu'il ya eu une attirance avec
une fille ça se couchent avec piquet jr
parle pas jamais puisque jours encore au
temps d'aimer ce que
chose qui va entendre ou même plus mais
moi je pense qu est d'emblée c'est la
convertir en temps on parlait des
conversations de nobert louise qu'ont
partagé en début de relation mais moi ça
fait partie des bordjis de deschamps
parle t j'en ai parlé justement avec
j'adore mon copain
puis il ya la même vision lui de la
famille tue la même vision que ce pc à 2
puis lui aussi il se voit pas partagé de
l'intimité avec autre que moi lui en
fait ces parents sont ensemble depuis
qu'ils ont 14 en tête lui il réalise
vraiment et le mariage puis le couple
sait vraiment ce qu'ils recherchent dans
sa vie un jour qui voter mais un jour
qui vous savez c'est un service avec moi
avec mauvaise mais mais en voulant dire
que c'est raté on en a parlé puis on est
ici comme tu le dis les gens évoluent
les gens changent on en parlera du le
même en ce moment non bâti un peu
différent mais c'est similaire à
certains points dans ce sens que si
j'entends une relation avec un gars qui
me dit d'emblée ça se peut les voir
envie d'aller voir ailleurs je ferai
comme je m'excuse marchera pas parce que
j'ai besoin de bâtir la confiance j'ai
besoin je pense que c'est possible mais
il faut que ce serait dans les comptes
tu as confiance
mais selon moi mon avis parce que cela
contre lesquels je vous dis c'est
définitif de la confiance ça se bâtit à
mon avis si oui tu vas faire confiance à
un étranger on voulait vraiment une
relation entre insectes et surtout je
pense encore une fois c'est très
différent pour la femme alors je connais
parce que c'est moi je suis au stade qui
est juste dans ma prochaine relation je
vais aborder sans faute mais pour une
femme de se permettre de tomber
vulnérables de porter enfin de mettre sa
carrière un petit peu de côté pendant
ex-directeur de là c'est un énorme
compromis je serais pas capable à ce
stade-ci de me dire ok mais pendant que
je veux sur mon jeu me couche avec des
filles en espagne le titre comprend très
bien la misère je pense que c'est un
afin d'égaliser ou c'est à ce niveau là
tu sais comme je fais des compromis mais
il y avait des trucs en soi que j'ai
envie de faire mon verre de vin aimé
sortir de file tory yémen et la fois que
je mets de côté le phoque au feuilleton
plaisir sexuel si je voudrais pas
bâtirons un début de relation dans cette
dynamique leur et moi j'ai plus de
facilité à l'accepter c'est la personne
me dit d'emblée qu'il cherche une
relation ouverte contrairement à si je
tombais un sens ça fait un an avec les
m'apporte une
ça m'est arrivé sauf qu'il est capable
de comprendre l'évolution comme je le
disais tantôt jeu capable ça va se
passer demain aussi de mon côté était
peut-être que lorsque moi j'ai dans ma
tête c'est super comme justement
interreliés le sexe l'amour la connexion
qui s'appuie peut-être comment n'ai je
vais arriver au point que je comme un
petit dico amont avec des fois j'ai
envie d'aller voir ailleurs parce
qu'elle est absolument rien l'amour que
j'ai pour mon deuil ses enfants ma
famille
peut-être que je serai capable de deux
fermes attaque la tuque de faire la part
des choses mais je pense que la notion
de respect des gens connus des coûts
plus bas puis me l'ont dit et en aurait
entre autres il dit les dix premières
années de notre relation tu m'avais dit
mme sheila et finir dans un mariage de
sont mariés entre enfin le mariage
ouvert la fête du malade c'est
impossible je le coupe qui se respect
que le plus le que j'ai rarement vu mais
ils se sont quand même donné un terrain
de jeu là dedans qui ont laissé si ça
marche pas c'est vachement lester mills
ont donné un terrain de jeu ayons des
règles voici comment ça se passe le soir
et ex y z il revient tout le temps que
sa maison se fait si tu fais ça c'est
tout est clair fac ci s'est faite dans
le respect encore une fois des
paramètres des nouveaux paramètres que
je pense est possible bataille cassard
est en bout de ligne il faut que les
deux suarez là dedans outre la fidélité
c'est un concept qui varient vraiment se
développer
quand la confiance la confiance c'est
juste un bris de confiance si mensonge
mensonge ou non dit qui équipe a exprimé
c'est là le bris de confiance et la
confiance nalement avarie dans selon les
relations les effets 100% en pitié pour
moi c'est tellement plus important à
limite d'assumer de tâches mais en tant
que personnes hantées fait donc dans tes
réflexions dans tes gestes d'aller
prononcer sur quelque chose que tu sais
peut-être qu'au premier abord ça va être
des plus par ta partenaire qui avait
peut-être mal réagir ou qu'il ou qu'elle
va mal réagi mais à tout le moins été en
ait
puis ça va tellement toujours être mieux
perçue à mon sens de la personne que je
suis là je vais parler pour moi
évidemment mais moi mettons on mari ike
et j'effectue sociaux auxquels j'ai
envie de te sociaux
ça se peut sur le coup ma réaction soit
vraiment poche parce que tu peux avoir
quand même peut-être en ferai ma
réflexion où l'image que j'avais de
notre couple de toi je suis je souhaite
qu'on vienne peuple combien important
pour ça sauf que je vois tellement avoir
un plus grand respect pour nous a juste
le fait d'avoir d'abord assumée de 13
mai puis de d'abord pris position là
dedans versus d'essayer de
le serpent dessous pièces et le ca bien
compliqué tu commences à jaipur dans
leurs mensonges
je tiens explosion en voici une
c'est seulement plus facile d'accès et
les défauts des autres quand les
personnes sont assumés es complètement
folle tu es voici ce que je suis est ce
que tu le prends tu le prends pas défaut
mais les caractéristiques et le couple
face à des défauts mais je parlais
c'était une autre optique pitts émettons
vous autres j'ai fait j'en attends à
part les quelques rires non mais tf1 l'a
fait mais cet épisode là que la ligne la
ligne la fidélité est différente pour
tout le monde qui cite accepter qu est
ce qui est acceptable puisqu'il pas
acceptable et où votre link dot m 2 où
une confiance est brisée mais ton dès
qu'il ya mensonge du cam ans aurait fait
que c'est pas nécessairement un acte
mais dès qu'un mensonge pour moi si non
même temps maîtresse que jusqu'où tu des
prêts à accepter les paramètres des
relations commerciales avec toi c'est
quoi vos paramètres mais tombe pour
rentrer en duration des droits qui jeta
l'aise avec ce parce que je vous
entendez dire puis douloureux parler de
ça parce que je sais que toi c'est
quelque chose qui est accepté dans ta
relation mais vous ne parliez d'e.on
ifans comme étant ceux de ballons en
défense une feuille qu'on peut
rencontrer à marianne mettons le c'est
un gros nom c'est toucher que ces pôles
que ces infections ses deux parents ces
deux paramètres qui sont distingués dans
le fond le tice et agdal fontaine ou
sohu et la limite métiers d'antan on
parlait d' orgueil
vraiment je sais de lorca utile pour le
poste j'ai pas le goût de me faire
comparer à ma voisine d'à côté cela
c'est la fille de ce rallye que je veux
a recroisé c'est autre chose
je pense qu'ils se trompent arrêt de
regagner dans tout ça rentre vraiment en
ligne de compte
ces bétons way congrès à mettre les
mettons un like les mettons ces maisons
moi je vous suis les deux
sauvages vince crawley va voir une de
vos photos je vois le hacking pas parce
que j'ai envie de coucher avec vous pas
parce que j'ai envie cela vous dit m
juste parce que votre photo puis un lag
cpld fois puis le genre tchèque ait eu
la caisse photo l'appareil parce que tu
es ja arment éponyme et y retrouve des
deux ça drôle putatif c'est fini le thé
sur quelqu'un qui peut-être plus
facilement atteint dans son ego pourrait
faire ses couettes à trouver des trous
rebelles ou 4 ou 6 août une nana puis ça
peuvent rapidement devenir une source de
conflit qui en réalité pour moi
l'acquis quelque chose ça veut rien dire
mais moi c'est moi même temps la
personne que tu vas là qui met plus le
contexte et le style de photos que tu
vas là qui sait si je vois une
corrélation en tout ce que tu like c'est
juste des filles et en lingerie jeu
comme on utilise comme la même façon
mais ton parce que moi c'est juste des
comptes de de bouffe d'autres prônent
archers comprend plus de mode belge je
me rends compte qu'on a pas le même fil
d'actualités locales car tu sais moi
c'est plus lent que ça me poserait
problème it et puis pas tant parce que
tu étais là qu'une photo de fait correct
le témoin au sujet en langues des photos
de coeur mais tellement nécessaire et
juste des gauchistes
même mon job va faire ça va la vie ce
parce que moi mais tandis que ma venue
alors je mets en fait je dirais que
c'est exactement ce que je pensais plus
la motivation derrière
si tu fais juste suivre des filles à
moitié à poil ou quoi que ce soit l'esma
les ce mois d'août est en fait que quand
tu es sur ton instagram dans le fond
quand j'étais à côté de toi ce que tu
fais c'est tuer qu'ils tuent d'autres
faits et ça me rend un peu inconfortable
et la pornographie et moi j'ai pas trop
graves excès mais je pense pas que si si
je pense pas qu'à toutes les fois que la
coupe du monde change à l'imaginaire et
à voir un film 3 et satellite si
j'imagine un peu
instagram un certain point c'est devenu
un peu la nouvelle pornographie c'est ça
serait wild en tabarnouche qui à toutes
les fois que ta blonde à l'essai de
parler toute ma fille de 3 ans mais
l'océan reste avec le tri sera aussi des
fois c'est comme jeter avec toi on
partage un moment et c'est mon école et
quoi que ce soit pendant ce temps notre
gentil secours dans ce défi
c'est plus sûr je pense c'est toute
l'espèce d'énergie derrière parce que tu
es moi j'en ai déjà j'ai déjà été celle
qui a fait convoquer malaise ça fait 28
photos du sud que tu l'angle à fait moi
je table on put même un prologue et
yamani un espèce de réflexion sans le
savoir qui s'impose et qui se fait de
façon inconsciente termes en étaient
convaincus c'est bien lourde dans le
fond mais sur la seule personne que j'ai
envie qu'ils me trouvent qui ôte ses
montres homme puis il l'a que jamais mes
photos mais il va les lacs et les faits
les blitz fed à 20 200 à moitié à poil
comme malaise
ça me rend malade a mangé un peu des
gossip la danske jeu comme en plus et
stitch pas à croiser au loblaws la
caisse quand même mal à l'aise j'ai pas
envie de titre dans ma relation jeu
comme j'ai envie que mon chum me fasse
chanter comme je suis la plus belle aux
tv tu parles trouvait donc pu aimer le
monde y passe pas à côté de l'occasion
de me faire sentir belle par exemple ces
jeux c'est polycom spa instagram le
problème et on les lit ses textes
c'est sans trop ce que tu regardes
jeunesse ça dérange aussi c'est parce
qu'il ya peut-être d'autres choses le
tristement six ans pour ça s'il ait des
photos mais dis jamais que tout rebelle
qui tu te sens pau délais ne sont pas
valorisées pour semer qui est un ballon
une thésaurisation qui venait et
équilibré a clairement marqué par un
manque d'évaluation
parce que si tu t'en sers toute
appartenance valorise puis je t'aime en
est mais en priorité dans sa vie plus
fun à faire juste le physique lorsque je
dis facile de tomber dans mais sait se
faire valoir en tant qu'humain en tant
que personne dans le quotidien
si tu te sens vraiment valoriser le
savez la capitale alors c'est lui qui
pilote la relation va super bien je
faisais le light peut-être le vote c'est
comme ça pour ça qu'ils apprécient c'est
une question de jeter de juste de choix
ou quoi que ce soit entier je pense au
site et julien on fera pas semblant
mater on se le dit souvent mais comme
nous sommes nuls et estivants sur
instagram tu veux pas on est dans la
trentaine quoi que ce soit plus on se
retrouve à notre homme qui se dit des
filles qui ont dix ans plus jeune s'ils
font ça me rend mal à l'aise si je crois
que c'est une femme qui me comparer puis
j'enlève rien de fait pour la dénigrer
mais dans ce sens qu on ait des
différences clairement on n'est plus mon
corps carrément nasri puis le chicago
qui met le en plus quand c'est des
personnes qui côtoient dans un domaine
exclu sa me rend mal à l'aise je sais
pas quoi dire
robin haase à saint vaast et nous on
suppose dégoûte un peu plus je m'en fous
des métiers lequel je vois que je suis
tellement peu instagram la même façon
qu'ils refusèrent gentil puis moi c'est
plus ce qui me rend malade a essayé moi
j'utilise je pense de façon aussi en pis
c'est pas dans l'optique de
des corps nus mais maintenant le mât
relation qui s p g c'est vraiment y rien
volaille qu'il d'abbottabad à mon fils
ça n'arrive pas toutes les affaires des
enfants ce genre les affaires que je
like ce genre est mon ami que ce soit un
livre de recettes vegan parce que je le
suis je suis 200 personnes sur instagram
chuter fait genre mettons le une fille
dans une relation avec moi
il a même fait une bonne action et
d'hommes faux son appréhension de ce qui
se passe sur instagram doit être
différente absolument six mois mais je
rentre dans un liking ce pluie des
justes des pays en inscrire ces genres
et weeds tabarnak parce que sinon il
existe des livres de recettes le nez
tandis que donne ce genre des rails tout
le temps puis des fois il ça va donner
sur mature avec des photos de filles en
lingerie pour ce genre qui émanent c'est
juste la faute au tir avec
l'appréhension guitare c'est la façon
que tu es le comportement si différente
c'est quand tu rencontres un gosse tu
sais que c'est son comportement sa
relation avec g
vous demandez changé au même titre qu
est ce que vous demandez changéens
certains traits de personnalité par
contre si ça te rend mal à la battant
ont renversé europe et je voudrais
arrêter parce que moi tout ce que je
veux c'est que mon homme ma maison c'est
lui qui est important mais je m'en fous
de la qu'ils n'apportent rien de l'adq
et ses sujets demain six candidats que
j'arrêterai pas aussi pour mon
partenaire c'est pour y faire sentir
mieux dans sa peau au level pourquoi je
voudrais continuer contamment un
comportement touche pas aux chicanes
avec mes parents j'ai pas besoin d'être
mon pied un adolescente en rébellion le
jeu comme nom moi je veux que ça soit
von ah maison faut que les lacs et m'en
fous des lacs
mais c'est pour ça que c'est wild
mettons quelqu'un est dans une relation
qui est qui qui mettons qu'il ne prend
pas consciemment la décision assez
mauvais ton parce que j'essaie d'être
bien formulé ce que je veux dire
quelqu'un qui prenant pas consciemment
la décision de faire juste un petit peu
attention pour ne pas liquider des
filles que tu peux croiser
montréal qui sont en brassière tout le
temps sachant très bien que ça se peut
que sa blonde tombe sur ces photos là
c'est pas un gros sacrifice j'ai comme
l'impression de faire de paix juste
passé ton pays tu sais c'est pas de bol
taipei de pattes de votre appétit si en
plus le live du ph
celle ci vaut rien pour toi parce que tu
as distributeurs ben c'est juste une
petite attention de pareilles je vais
pas faire exprès de la caisse maladie
si le lag n'est rien pour toi si tu es
mort discute ça continue ton
comportement sachant très bien qu'à la
maison ça amène des deux tous des
appréhensions un inconfort expiré xen
bellelay ce mois d'août et on live
ouvrir mais ils m'aiment pas aussi même
passer de l'autre côté
dans les deux cas précis puis on a eu un
épisode avec mehdi ben saïd en chemin
qui ont parlé du dtm sur les réseaux
sociaux comment ça se passe et plus
zemmour je demande à tous la fille
m'intéresse pas je les fais dans
l'optique de thé ouais piété comme si je
lègue deux photos de suite là est ce
parce que je cherche mon attention sur
ces écosystèmes style rock ne passe pas
inaperçu m'attends à ce qu'il aille
beaucoup
non parce qu'il connut aussi tout le
monde dont la jamaïque est pas remédier
à la file
de 25 ans qui outre sa g qui reçoit
delahaye de mehdi ben saïdane il le
remarque plus que double s'impose alors
tu dirais qu'il devrait encore choisi
resterai mais pas parce que c'est une
personnalité connue avant le main
comportement verse histoire mais lui son
intention t-il il dit son intention
qu'un kilo tandis que les tensions il
peut être différent que le tipi petit
d'un côté oui je comprends d'aidé faire
attention pas aussi de l'autre côté si
pour toi si c'est un haut d'un une
question à se poser est pourquoi te
dérange tant souci c'est que la
colocation est important qu'ils tissent
et mettons ta partenaire at explique un
peu voici ma situation ici recticel
exemple dans la situation actuelle
justement tout life à table on à titi
comme magasin le temps plus justement a
vécu avec les filles j'aurai vécu
pendant deux heures le sens volailles et
les photos étaient d'un coup 4 x 4 comme
est non je vais continuer à l'ail qui
était faux coffre parce que c'est pas un
genre de combos qui est important ça va
vraiment changer ton bonheur en jeu non
plus mais si je pense pas que tu te
tiens tu appartenant tout un tas
relations sous le titre je pense pas
qu'il soit faire un nom je vais mettre
mon pilotage c'est pas vrai qu'avant
depuis les tissus qui est tellement né
savent mettrent toutes les façons
différentes sycoparc le soumettons si la
fille team et on chez pol à cédric sa
femme blonde qui sa blonde a dit
j'aimerais que tu allais des laïcs et
les photos apesi sa meilleure amie des
inconnus le papa d'amy les amis je suis
suisse et ex y de saint jérôme que tu ne
connais pas tu l'as eu toutes ces photos
en lingerie dessus mais j'ai un petit
malaise le défi surtout de parler d'eux
mais duke doucet dalhem aussi dirigé par
une personnalité publique ginon j'ai peu
le goût que le monde ait quelque chose à
dire sur mon copain non non grata fort
aussi qui est une méthode de ce mode de
jeu l'attaqué des photos sans dire c'est
pour attirer l'attention de cette
personne le pipeau et pour être un objet
je suis d homme que je connais tu es
maintenant même les filles même les
filles que je suis des personnalités
québécoises this is ventes montrent que
je connais auquel j'ai déjà côtoyé selon
tes je suis beaucoup juste des comptes
fâché en mettant des filles en mauvaises
langues question tu parles de tell halaf
et de saint-eustache qui prendraient
toutes ces photos cl en un joli me
tourner je comprends je comprend mais
mais la question que je pose est si mal
on a fait ce qu'elle veut disons que je
veux poser c'est pourquoi on est abonné
à cette personne mais non mais je veux
côtoyé c'est une amie travaux c'est
parti là je te parle je ne crois pas
vraiment quelqu'un qui croie finder je
trouve quelqu'un qui est chaud puis
mettons cartes et si le bateau est ce
que tu veux c'est acquis sauf que
mohamme et ont même aujourd'hui georges
était de l'aménagement instagram nages
et 200 personnes que je suis j'ai
vraiment réduit au maximum le type juste
du monde que je connais ou des affaires
qui m'intéresse pas entièrement vrai
parce que j'ai réalisé que mon feydeau
finale s'est défait en bic en bikini en
lingerie puis que ça m'a mené riem à
mériel puis que j'allais encore - like
et une photo parce que ça m'amène gens
rien à ceux qui qui me procurait quoi
que ce soit c'est juste du juste d'aider
des faits en maillot c'est comme un gem
se voir des femmes en lingerie quai mais
en même temps quand j'ouvre mon seul
pour ddm professionnel à du monde
invités du monde au podcast dessus que
je vous mets ton dans un meeting de
business sur ton fils puis à ses juges à
1 à 5 c koi tu fais 2 pourquoi c'est que
ça m'amène au fait que je vendais si je
veux voir des faits en lingerie mettons
de jouer activement vont défiler en
lingerie le projet que ça fasse partie
de ma vie au détour des quand je me fais
mon fils je vais aller sur femme léger
sur google si j'arrive à en trouver je
veux trouver type est dans le fond la
question je me pose
puis je la lance dans l'univers ça
m'amène au final ça m'amène strictement
rien strictement rien piché que ça
t'amène auriez non plus mais non mais en
réalité j'en suis pas dans le saut puis
j'en suis surtout pas de nouvelles
depuis que regarder mes anciennes séries
a été bougés à s'user aucun compte de
même à 20 qui compte c'est d'avoir un
podcast pouvoir sur des influences au
fpi le evening technologie follow parce
qu'on se connaît depuis l'est pas mais
je pense pas qu'on a reçues personnes
que je dise que je catégorise dans la
catégorie que je te parle des gens qui
je connais je sais j'en suis pas non
plus n'en suis pas non plus mais dans
les pas de personnes qui très nourrie
par les agréables
si on pose des trucs sur nos comptes on
est active sur génération satie couac
mais comme moi perso c'est rare que je
passe des heures à tout coup tout moi
surtout terme et on cherche une
recherche balles et par mots clés je
vais aller voir les comptes c'est des
fois que ça m'arrive comme tout le monde
me perdre ou c'est d'avoir besoin de
m'inspirer message est quand même un
objectif quand je m'en veut consommer
mais moi je suis beaucoup plus de compte
que deux personnes montées plus de
comptes à matton qui parle de trucs qui
m'intéresse je sus des personnalités et
ils ont le prix l'exemple précis des
lobes frontaux gamme qui reste quand
même quelque chose de vraiment tu es
très de notre génération désertion plus
tôt
superflu en surface pas trop difficile
mais c'est officiel on rame était mon
point jeu à mener c'est qu'il met ton
autre exemple je marche dans la rue avec
ton ou ta partenaire pi le cross
quelqu'un pile tu vois que le partenaire
regarde l'autre qui pleure puis le team
et on s'est tu déranges ça me dérange
pas non puis même sauvage cam était
vraiment belle
parce que tous les deux c'est cette
année c'est un ego qui viennent y
chercher où est vraiment une raison
valable et valide est valable de n'avoir
pas confiance dans le secteur nation
mais quand je croise demandant riches
capables de voir que ok il a une beauté
qui détonne et puis il n'ya pas d'en
parler avec mon chum pillent pas de
malaise général qui leur pose une
question de croiser une belle ou
poubelles personne si je pense qu'en
général pour l'avoir déjà vécu deux
c'est une personne qui est assez
confiante même si je peux avoir un
certain manque d'estimé un certain
niveau mais risqué quand les gens
exclure exode commence à déranger ou a
détonné la perception que j'ai deux mois
où la confiance que j'ai en cause parce
qu'il ya clairement ce niveau là
personne ne se sont jamais la personne
c'est comme pourquoi tout d'un coup
cette personne-là qui avait aucune
importance dans ma vie commençait à
occuper mes pensées puis ça me rend
inconfortable quand cette personne là
est proche de ma vie puisque y ait
quelque chose d'autre qui a été créé le
titre c'est pas juste arrivé de même le
triple c log foutu question petit
décortique commenté meir et le vrai bobo
finalement loti plus patrick et dans ta
relation jeu demain et du manque de
confiance en étant partenaire pourquoi
parfait télé grecque raison de toutes
les raisons valables ou jean strike et a
besoin de facebook pour attirer tous les
droits sans toi que nous faisons pour le
savoir de baisse et se logent pas
d'ambiguïté d'ambiguïté moi c'est
l'ambiguïté qui m'ont dit que ces îles
et l'ambiguïté les zones grises baissé
et les attaques sont ambigus le thé
comme je sais peu a déjà gens très
simples à voir un exemple concret mais
j'ai quand je rentre dans une raçon
malgré que j'ai des blessures j'arrive
tout temps dans le petit quoi ce qui est
énorme je te fais totalement confiance
créé des doutes des tullistes des
ambiguïtés ben c'est là que je vais
commencer à être inconfortable c'est là
que pour ma part baissé c'est presque
vouée à l'échec parce que après comment
tu fais pour venir c'était des
intentions derrière un titre c'est
encore une fois trop mignon terrain de
jeu mais si tu le sais que j'étais le
tell tale bendriss pourquoi es-tu la
personne qui va les nourrir
je sais pas ça fait pression dans
l'attenté c'est un peu comme ça c'est
peut-être justement bas canada et
c'était sûrement pas le même discours
mais je pense qu'en date d'aujourd'hui
ou dans ma dernière relation tiges de
manger encore des blessures mais je suis
conscient depuis je travaille
j'arrive dans un terrain qui est
tellement cool il s'est tellement blanc
le sait juste des pissenlits freixe
livres d'ici le printemps le rhum c'est
frais frais et le factice et consorts la
mauvaise herbe
parce que des trucs se sont implantés de
l'extérieur après qu'on ait recommencé à
entamer notre relation parce que c'est
moi j'arrive toujours avec un climat de
l'onu comme je cible
ouais voici mes faiblesses je capable de
le reconnaître moi-même omagad ya ceux
qui montent en ont acquis kate s'étaient
petits démons intérieurs
je suis capable de tout reconnaître fact
est clairement le simon chant depuis son
lit commence à se transformer en
marchant de mauvaises herbes
c'est peut-être moment là qu'ils m'ont
nourri tout seul près c'est le foot
analyse la relation et puis demande à
ton partenaire je mens 2 de te pardonner
pour des gestes qu'ils étaient commis
bien foutu ou un petit web et wap d'état
2 1 puis que tu sois conscient que cette
personne dans le futur va voir peut-être
certaines blessures pu voir que tu sois
là pour la rassurer et et tu peux pas
juste du hockey je m'excuse on passe à
autre chose non c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe mon homme trompe quand il va
falloir que tu récupères cette confiance
ça peut prendre du temps
puis c'est ça des fois que les gens
comprennent pas quand ils commettent
arrêteront des bris de confiance ont
commandé ces boules ggyc ont pris le
chemin inverse l'importation et et
responsabilise en fait de l'impact de
leurs actions
certains points c'est d'assumer ses
actions de comprendre la réaction de
l'autre face aux actions que toi tu as
commis c'était secteur responsabilité à
mon sens de devenir réparer un peu la
situation tu peux pas juste que j'ai
fait je m'excuse mais le travail la tuer
parce que je t'emmerde tabarnouche
côtoient ainsi que le nom il ya une
raison pourquoi je devine mans il faut
que tu travailles avec moi pour qu'on
puisse m
m longuet ou réparer la blessure en tant
que témoin je le vois vraiment comme
sauter après ce mois je fais jeter en
relation je veux tellement tout le monde
soit content parce que c'est que qu'est
ce que j'ai pu faire pour te rendent
ainsi qu'un pas moins un temps mais on
en avait parlé je pense jamais paru
justement dans le sud avec renault on
parlait de fruits dans le substitut a
servi une fois que mes partenaires
avaient fui dans montréal puis moi j'ai
même pas deux secondes 10 mai qu'elle
était 16 des intentions derrière voilà
je vais t'en mon dieu qu'est-ce que j'ai
créé pour que tout d'un coup je m'excuse
ya clairement quelque chose que j'ai
fait des progrès pour que comme tout
d'un coup tu commences à douter de moi
je vois c'est juste la tuque mais fox et
j'ai même pas pensé à mon dû songer
c'est ingrat c'était respectent même pas
les gg c'est thomas gold j'ai clairement
créé 1 2 tous soumis quelque chose dans
ma relation qui a fait qu'il a douté de
moi plus je me sentais mal c'est moi je
suis dans une relation je vis tellement
bien faire j'étais je fais plein
d'erreurs mais je te mange comme ok mais
dumont qui agita de pas correct parce
que clairement c'est parce que je
l'écris le métier encore une façon de
faire
as peur que ça se peut que tu ailles
justement flirter que la ligne de la
confiance d'un partenaire qui fait
qu'elle est tellement c'est que qu'il
faut qu'ils regardent et peut-être même
vous trouvez le dauphin où ils vous
trouvez de le faire avec les quelque peu
denses mais ça se peut aussi qu'un
absolument rien à te reprocher peut-être
tout était clean piqué le après sa belle
et ça en dit beaucoup plus sur l'eau
personnes qui sur terre
ça dépend vraiment des classes ont
complètement complètement ça fait du
bien également
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir écouté ce
podcast jusqu'à la fin de ce pas que
vous avez apprécié la conversation ça
prouve que vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe bien sûr p tu es a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres pétuaud nous est
ce que on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi
de la conversation combien
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on abordés pendant
le podcast donc allez sur notre page
rituels les liens vers ses avoirs dans
la description du podcast qui remercie
encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fonte